bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre la discussion
générale du projet de loi relatif au
soins psychiatriques à mes côtés pour en
parler Jacquy lemen sénateur socialiste
d'il Villen bonjour Alors c'est une
séance un petit peu inédite particulière
car pour la première fois depuis la
révision constitutionnelle le texte
amendé en commission a été rejeté c'est
donc le texte de l'Assemblée nationale
qui vient en séance ça va donc être un
petit peu particulier tout à fait donc
bon c'est effectivement c'est une
première avec la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2009 c'est le texte
qui sort en principe de la commission
qui est présenté et là ce texte a
explosé si on peut dire en commission
puisque
les les les auteurs du
texte notamment la droite ne sont pas
tombés d'accord et donc il y a plus de
texte Tex et on revient sur le texte de
la de l'Assemblée nationale qui lui-même
était déjà en retrait par rapport à la
position de la Commission des affaires
sociales qui elle-même était en retrait
par rapport à la position de leur
rapporteur donc ça c'est une réflexion
une première réflexion sur la forme sur
le fond c'est un texte qui est considéré
comme les psychiatres et une partie de
l'opposition comme un texte davantage
sécuritaire que sanitaire vous pouvez
nous en dire plus tout à fait don
l'ature ce texte est sécuritaire en fait
c'est un texte de circonstance pour
répondre à un moment donné à un drame
qui s'est passé
à côté de de grenob et pour bon répondre
à une volonté du Président de la
République qui fonctionne un peu comme
ça sur un mode émotionnel répondant par
un texte ou une loi à un vrai problème
il était nécessaire de faire une grande
loi concernant la maladie mentale la
psychiatrie puisque c'était prévu
d'ailleurs dans la loi de 90 qui était
juste la voie avant 1990 27 juin il
était prévu que dans les 5 ans on devait
faire une loi pour et là ce n'est pas le
cas avec ce texte et pas du tout là
c'est c'est une caricature avec
d'ailleurs aade de consultation et et
surtout dedans on voit bien l'ossature
je le disais à l'instant sécuritaire
mais aussi avec des positions qui sont
mal compris par le notamment par les
psychiatres mais aussi par les autres
professionnels c'est tout l'aspect de
judiciarisation hein alors si vous
voulez c'est c'est mal compris par y a
une sorte de de garde vue sanitaire de
72 he ça c'est un point critique voilà
bon il a y a cette notion de de garde vu
euh qui qui en malgré que nos nos
adversaires de droite disent que c'est
pas le cas c'est le cas dans les fait
hein et puis il y a d'autres éléments
aussi qui sont extrêmement préoccupants
par exemple pour des euh malades qui ont
été dans les unités malades difficiles
ou qui ont été condamnés antérieurement
parce qu'ils avaient commis des euh des
délis dans cadre de drame bien souvent
vous étz d'ailleurs sans soin hein tout
ceci euh le texte initial voulait que ça
soit gardé en mémoire hein c'est-à-dire
qu' casier de casier l'opposition pour
un droit à l'oubli il ne faut plus avoir
de casier judiciaires concernant les
soins psyatri qui mettent une limite il
faut pouvoir limiter dans le temps nous
on ne perd jamais de vu qu'il s'agit de
malade hein et l'aspect sanitaire
qualité des soins doit être premier même
si on est d'accord qu'il doit y avoir un
équilibre entre le sanitaire la santé
des malades n'oublion pas que c'est des
malades
la liberté liberté les libertés
publiques dont il do aussi bénéficier et
la sécurité de l'ensemble des
concitoyens dans eux-mêmes d'ailleurs
mais ils doivent pas être rejetés de la
cité comme on le sent actuellement dans
ce texte sur pas mal de certains
psychiatres s'inquiè également des
pouvoirs qui seront donnés au préfet ils
pourront se prononcer pour
l'hospitalisation en fait le maintien en
hospitalisation de certaines personnes
contre des avis médicaux tout à fait
donc ça la profession et nous-même on
peut pas acccep
on a présenté des amendements d'ailleurs
la commission des lois dans ce cadre là
présente aussi des amendements et que
son rapporteur monsieur le cerf qui
Acquier en ce qui nous concerne des avis
qui requèrent des avis favorables de
notre part nous allons d'ailleurs
reprendre un certain nombre
d'amendements qui avaient été présentés
par l'ancienne rapporteur madame Dini
hein sur ce qui est au cœur de cette loi
les soins sans consentement ambulatoires
hein qui est une aggravation si vous
voulez dans les outils pour les
traitements à côté de l'hospitalisation
d'office de la possibilité de soigner
les malades d'ailleurs il y a une espèce
de paradoxe de vouloir soigner les gens
contre leur gris c'est encore plus vrai
en psychiatrie où la notion de confiance
entre le psychiatre et et son et son
malade l'alliance thérapeutique si on
peut dire requierre de la confiance
c'est pas un rend obligatoire avec tous
les problèmes pratiques que ça porte une
dernière question Jacquie le mène vu ce
qui s'est passé en commission des
Affaires social la semaine dernière
est-ce que le Sénat pourrait rejeter ce
texte ben écoutez nous on va faire tout
ce qu'on peut pour il soit rejeté je
pense que euh il y a une chance de
renvoyer ce texte sur sa table de
travail et que l'on puisse pouvoir aller
plus loin alors il y avait la question
euh du du fait que la Constitution s'est
prononcée hein sur une question
préalable de constitutionnalité qui met
une date qui est le 1er août mais on
peut parfaitement scinder ce texte hein
et euh mettre essentiellement ce qui ne
peut pas échapper à cette date du 1er
août et puis aller vers une véritable
loi qui soit une loi dans l'intérêt de
toutes les parties concernées et
notamment des malad merci Jacquie lemen
d'avoir répondu à nos questions tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle du
Sénat pour suivre la discussion générale
de ce texte relatif au soins
psychiatriques très bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale relatif au droit et à la
protection des personnes faisant l'objet
de soin psychiatriqu et aux modalités de
leur prise en charge je voudrais vous
rappeler mes chers collègues que la
commission des affaires sociales a
rejeté lors de sa réunion du 3 mai le
texte résultant de ses travaux en
conséquence et en application du premier
alinéa de l'article 42 de notre
Constitution la discussion porte donc
sur le texte adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale
et texte transmis par le
gouvernement Monsieur Michel
pour qui se fonde sur sur les condition
de l'application de l'article nOUVEAULe
36 42 de la Constitution monsieur le
Président en effet nous vivons une
situation inédite qui pourrait se
reproduire puisque le texte qui vient en
séance c'est celui qui nous a été
transmis donc celui de l'Assemblée
nationale ce matin la commission des
affaires sociales a été réunie elle a
désigné un nouveau rapporteur a-t-il
fait un rapport je l'ignore je
n'assistais pas à cette réunion
certainement qu'il en a fait un il nous
le dira tout à l'heure et ensuite la
commission a procédé à l'examen des
amendements
elle est arrivée jusqueà la fin de
l'article 1er me dit-on et donc elle est
reconvoquée demain matin à 9h30 pour
examiner la suite des amendements
or demain matin à 9h30 d'après ce que
j'ai lu dans les convocations
or
les services du Sénat avaient décidé que
le lundi 9 mai à 11h était de la date
limite de dépôt des amendements on se
trouve donc dans une dans une situation
originale où la séance commence tous les
amendements n'ont pas été
examinés puisque demain matin est-ce que
la Commission ira jusqu'à la fin des
amendements une 500 paraî-il on n'en
sait rien dans ces conditions monsieur
le Président deux questions se posent la
première qui a trit à notre ordre du
jour puisque nous sommes convoqués
d'après l'ordre du jour cet après-midi
ce soir et cette nuit
or la Commission est réunie demain matin
à 9h30 cuid de la séance de nuit de
toute façon nous ne pourrons pas
dépasser l'article 1er puisque pour le
reste les amendements n'ont pas été
examinés deuxièmement je vous demande
également monsieur le Président de
prolonger le délai de dépôt des
amendements car enfin il est absol
ubuesque que la Commission n''est pas
encore examiné tous les amendements et
que nous ne puissions plus en déposer au
moins jusqu'à la fin de la discussion
générale comme cela se faisait avant la
réforme constitutionnelle voilà le sens
de mon rappel au
règlement je vous je vous donne acte de
ce rappel au règlement je voudrais
simplement préciser que ce sont pas des
services du Sénat mais la Conférence des
présidents qui je le rappelle rassemble
les vice-présidents du Sénat les
présidents des groupes politiques et les
présidents de
commission qui dans la réunion du 6
avril avait fixé concernant le projet de
loi relatif au soins psychiatriques le
délai limite pour le dépôt des
amendement en séance au lundi 9 mai à
11h bien entendu elle ignorait le 6
avril si la commission parviendrait à
élaborer un texte c'est le cas général
et ça n'a rien d'exceptionnel dans la
prévisibilité de nos travaux
ou bien donc la Commission élabore et
publie un texte sur lequel porte la
discussion en séance dans ce cas les
amendements s'appliqueront au texte de
la
commission où la commission n'élabore
pas de texte dans ce cas les amendements
portent sur le Tex adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale et transmis par le
gouvernement ce qui est le cas en espèce
autrement dit la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents s'applique
quel que soit l'issue des travaux de la
commission je voudrais vous le rappeler
d'une manière générale pour que nos
travaux aient un certain ordre au surplu
le 4 mai dernier la Conférence des
Présidents a confirmé ce délai limite au
vu issu de la décision du rejet du texte
de la commission puisque nous le savions
au moment nous nous sommes réunis par
voie de conséquence lorsque la
Conférence des Présidents a confirmé le
délai limite il était évident que les
amendements porteraient sur texte
transmis par le
gouvernement les sénateurs et les
groupes en avaient une claire conscience
dans la mesure où les 480 amendements
qu'ils ont déposé pent bien sur le texte
transmis par le gouvernement second
point de votre intervention mon cher
collègue qui est celui jusqu'où peut-on
aller si j'ai bien résumé j'ai bien noté
qu'il y avait un peu plus de 180
amendements sur le seul article prer ce
qui laisse en l'occurrence à la
Commission le temps nécessaire pour
aller au delelà enfin je rappelle qu' en
coordination avec le gouvernement le
président de séance et nous échangerons
quelques mots sur ce
point au moment de la transmission de la
présidence de séance peut à tout moment
en lien avec la Commission et la
présidente de la commission décider des
interruptions nécessaires pour que nos
travaux sur un sujet très important
puissent se dérouler dans les meilleures
conditions possibles je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut voir et envisager la
suite de nos travaux voilà le point que
je pouvais vous faire et nous allons
maintenant si vous le voulez un autre
rappel au règlement monsieur
ficher je vous donne la parole sûrement
fondé sur l'article 36 vous avez compris
monsieur le Président oui il compris non
moi ce que je voudrais dire partager
bien sûr le point de vue qui vient
d'être
émis
mais il faut que l'on arrive a travaillé
dans d'autres conditions monsieur le
Président nous savons fort bien et la
Conférence des Présidents y participant
je sais fort bien que nous avions
décidé de cet ordre du jour des
conditions de travail mais je dois dire
que compte tenu de l'évolution du
dossier et qui aurait pu imaginer que
l'on sorte de la commission sans texte
voté c'est-à-dire revenant au texte du
Gouvernement bon cela montre bien quel
peut-être finalement euh les différents
points de vuees qui peuvent s'exprimer
puisque la majorité à un moment donné
désavoue le rapport la madame la
rapporteur madame la Présidente
rapporteur et que l'on soit obligé de
désigner et bien un nouveau rapporteur
cela s'est fait très rapidement ce matin
et je crois que l'on n' pas intérêt à
continuer à travailler de cette
manière-là car bon cela discrédite d'une
certaine manière le travail
parlementaire et cela nous tenons à le
dire nous sommes un certain nombre à
attacher beaucoup d'importance au
travail en commission mais à force
d'accélérer on parle maintenant je ne
veux pas anticiper sur le
que nous aurions encore une session
extraordinaire qui dépasserait le 14
juillet et bien cela me paraît comme
insoutenable et c'est d'une certaine
façon traité par le mépris et bien les
parlementaires de travailler dans de
telles conditions je tenais au nom de
mon groupe à le raeler
merci nous vous donnons acte de ce
rappel au règlement nons passer la
discussion génér la parole est à
Monsieur Michel Mercier garde des saau
ministre de la Justice et des
Libertés avez la parole monsieur le
gardessau merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des lois mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs projet de loi
qui est soumis à votre examen vise à
renforcer les droits et la protection
des personnes faisant l'objet de soin
psychiatrique et à mieux individualiser
leur prise en charge notamment par la
création de soins ambulatoires sans
contentement il met aussi ce projet
l'institution judiciaire face à un
véritable défi et ce à très brève
échéance puisque dans sa décision du 26
novembre 2010 le Conseil constitutionnel
saisit d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité à donné au
législateur jusqu'au 1er août 2011 pour
mettre notre législation en conformité
avec la Constitution à défaut toutes les
mesures d'hospitalisation sans
consentement d'office ou à la demande
d'un tiers en cours font l'objet d'une
mainlevée automatique je veux bien sûr
insister sur les conséquences fâcheuses
qui s'attacheraient à tout retard dans
l'adoption du projet de loi je veux
aussi rappeler parce que il faut
toujours le faire que cette QPC est
naturellement une des conséquence de la
réforme de la Constitution qui a été
adoptée en 2008 et que l'on voit chaque
jour que cette réforme est une réforme
extrêmement protectrice des droits et
des libertés constitutionnellement
garanties et je pense que chaque jour
ceux qui ont oublié de voter cette
réforme le regrette amèrement et je vois
à monsieur mzard qui en est
exemple justement c'est bien est qu'on
peut lui reprocher donc le volet est
judiciaire du projet vise à mettre le
droit français en parfaite conformité
avec les exigences constitutionnelle que
requiert donc la décision du Conseil du
26 novembre 2010 en application de
l'article 66 de la Constitution dispose
qu'il est nécessaire d'instaurer un
contrôle systématique des mesures
d'hospitalisation sans consentement par
le juge judiciaire gardien des libertés
individuelles l'occasion donc nous a
donné une nouvelle fois de constater
l'efficience de cette révision de 2008
et je veux dire que le texte qui vous
est soumis est d'une ampleur comparable
à celui qui est relatif à la réforme de
la garde à vue et il aboutit à la
création d'une nouvelle procédure
permettant de garantir de façon
systématique le droit DESP
le projet de loi prévoit ainsi un
contrôle de plein droit du juge dans les
15 jours suivant l'admission en
hospitalisation complète le projet
apporte une garantie supplémentaire en
imposant qu'après ce premier contrôle le
juge judiciaire intervienne de 6 mois en
6 mois aussi longtemps que se poursuit
la mesure ce nouveau dispositif qui
renforce notablement la protection des
droits et liberté des patients par
rapport à la situation actuelle est
pleinement conforme aux exigences
constitutionnelles
en insturance ce contrôle systématique
nous marquons un véritable progrès mais
le nouveau dispositif exigera des
jurridiction un effort supplémentaire
considérable car ce sont près de 80000
décisions juridictionnelles nouvelles
par an qui sont à prévoir pour permettre
la mise en œuvre de cette réforme dans
les meilleures conditions possibles j'ai
d'ailleurs obtenu du Premier ministre la
création de 80 emplois de magistrats et
de 70 emplois de greffiers
supplémentaires ainsi qu'une enveloppe
complémentaire de 5 millions d'euros
pour financer l'aide
juridictionnelle à l'issue de la
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale nous
sommes parvenus à un dispositif
équilibré respectueux de l'intérêt des
patients et conforme aux exigences
constitutionnelles j'appelle votre
attention sur cet équilibre et sur les
risques que l'on ferait courir à la
viabilité du dispositif de contrôle en
voulant toujours plus de juges là même
où son intervention n'est pas absolument
nécessaire gardons-nous
de confondre les rôles en voulant faire
jouer au juges celui de l'autorité
administrative ou celui du médecin la
réforme ambitieuse que nous sommes en
train de bâtir ensemble ne fonctionnera
que si chacun remplit l'Office qui lui
revient à l'autorité sanitaire la
responsabilité des soins et de
l'expertise médicale à l'autorité
administrative le maintien de l'ordre
public à l'autorité judiciaire la
garantie des libertés individuelles je
voudrais insister sur ce que doit être
au sens des exigences constitutionnelles
l'office du juge dans le contrôle des
mesures de soins psychiatrique sans
consentement qu'il s'agisse de
l'hospitalisation complète ou des
nouvelles mesures de soins ambulatoires
sans
consentement en matière
d'hospitalisation sans consentement ou
hospitalisation complète le texte
prévoit un dispositif de contrôle
automatique qui permet à chacun des
acteurs d'exercer ses prérogative dans
le respect des droits du patient je veux
rappeler ce qu'est ce dispositif le
niveau contrôle de plein droit dans les
15 jours de l'admission en
hospitalisation sans consentement puis
le cas échéant renouvellement en quelque
sorte du contrôle tous les 6 mois permet
au juges de liberté et de la détention
de s'assurer de la proportionnalité de
la privation de liberté que constitue
l'hospitalisation complète et par ce
dispositif nous mettons notre droit en
pleine conformité à avec les exigences
de l'article 66 de la Constitution le
texte apporte des garanties procédurales
supplémentaires en prévoyant que le juge
statut au terme d'un débat
contradictoire et que tout patient qui
ne serait pas en mesure de comparaître
personnellement pourra être représenté
par un avocat le texte prévoit également
que les audiences pourront se tenir par
visionférence si le patient y consent et
si des motifs médicaux le justifient ce
recours à la visionférence
nous permettra de paliier certaines
difficultés pratiques évidentes afin de
permettre au juges de statuer dans les
délais extrêmement courts qui lui sont
impartis pour décider du maintien en
hospitalisation complète alors même que
le juge en raison de son caractère
polyvalent ne sera pas en charge de ce
seul contentieux afin également de
répondre à la difficulté d'amener les
malades dans les tribunaux cette mesure
impliquera l'aménagement de salalles
spécifique au sein des hôpitaux je suis
tout à fait conscient que certaines
pathologies sont incompatibles avec la
tenue d'une visionférence et que le
déplacement des malades est parfois
impossible c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle la proposition de Monsieur le
rapporteur le surf de prévoir un
certificat médical pour la
visioconférence et l'utilisation de ces
salles spécifiques pour la tenue
d'audience foraine a retenu mon
attention mais lui dit qu' il
appartiendra bien sûr toujs au juges de
décider en dernier ressort on le voit
cette nouvelle procédure judiciaire va
profondément modifier les pratiques des
tribunaux et des hôpitaux et justifiera
une mobilisation de tous pour parvenir à
ce que cette réforme soit au 1er août
prochain un
succès monsieur ficher je veux rappeler
que le professionnalisme des des
gendarmes des policiers des magistrats
et des avocats a rendu applicable en 5
minutes la réforme de la garde à vue je
suis sûr que les professionnels qui sont
impliqués dans cette réforme feront les
mêmes efforts nous avons des moyens à
leur donner et c'est la raison pour
lesquell il faut aussi que le Parlement
garde la bonne mesure des
choses cette mobilisation de tous que
nous appelons et que nous savons se
réalis est à la hauteur de l'importance
de cette réforme sachons maintenant ne
pas trop en faire en demandant au juges
de prendre des décisions qui ne relèvent
pas de leur office aucune autorité ne
doit ni ne peut se substituer à une
autre le juge n'a pas plus vocation à se
substituer à à l'autorité administrative
qu'il n'a vocation à intervenir dans le
champ des autorités sanitaires c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ne m' paraaît
pas souhaitable que le juge puisse
lorsqu'il est saisi d'une demande de
main levée de l'hospitalisation sans
consentement ordonner des soins
ambulatoires ce serait dévoyer le rôle
du juge en effet nous sommes ici dans
une matière civile et non dans une
matière pénale les personnes
hospitalisées ne sont pas des
délinquants mais des patients or le juge
civil n'a pas les moyens d'assurer le
suivi des soins qui l'ordonnerait
contrairement au juges pénal qui dispose
des services d'insertion et de probation
pour effectuer ce suivi prévoir une
telle mesure reviendrait à demander au
juges d'ordonner une obligation de soin
sans moyen de la contrôler ou de la
sanctionner ce qui n'est pas acceptable
confier au juge une telle mission ce
serait en outre oublier que le juge n'a
aucune légitimité pour arbitrer entre
les très nombreuses modalités de sou in
auquel peut concrètement renvoyer un
programme de soi et l'on ne saurait
envisager que le juge doivent se borner
à ordonner des soins sans en définir les
modalités précises ni être en mesure
d'apprécier le degré d'atteinte au
liberté qu'elles impliquent aller dans
cette direction imposerait au juges de
recourir dans tous les cas à une
expertise et de s'en remettre en
pratique à ses conclusions ce qui là non
plus ne serait pas satisfaisant comment
en effet ne pas rappeler la lourde tâche
qui est déjà confiée aux experts
psychiatres dont le nombre trop réduit
ne permettra pas de faire face à cette
nouvelle mission qui reviendrait à leur
demander dans des délais très contraints
de proposer le cas échéant un protocole
de soin en outre le risque que le juge
ne puisse obtenir ses expertises dans
des délais impartis lui imposera de
prendre une décision non éclairée ce qui
n'est pas davantage satisfaisant c'est
enfin pour des raisons du même ordre que
je ne peux à forceerie que vous inviter
à refuser toute extension systématique
de l'intervention du juge aux nouvelles
mesures de soin ambulatoire sans
consentement un programme de soins sans
consentement na pas vocation à conduire
à l'exercice d'une contrainte physique à
l'égard du patient il ne s'agit pas de
soin forcés à la différence de
l'hospitalisation complète
l'intervention automatique du juge
n'apparaît pas dès l'URE nécessairire
pour autant cela ne veut pas dire que
les patients concernés n'auront pas
accès au juges le recours au juges
restera toujours possible à la demande
du patient ou de ses proches selon des
modalités qui ont été clarifiées et
simplifiées par le décret du 20 mai
dernier le projet de loi prévoit donc
des garanties proportionnées à chaque
situation et permet à chacun des acteurs
médicaux administratifs et judiciaires
de rester dans son rôle avec avec un
recours juridictionnel systématique pour
l'hospitalisation complète selon les
modalités que j'ai évoqué à l'instant et
un recours juridictionnel facultatif
pour les soins ambulatoires sans
consentement un tel équilibre procédural
assure la garantie effective des droits
des patients tout en leur permettant de
bénéficier des soins les plus adaptés à
leur situation je crois par ailleurs
qu'en permettant la saisine à la fois du
juge administratif pour apprécier la
légalité externe des mesures de
placement et du juge judiciaire tel que
je viens de l'expliquer le système
français offrira des garanties fortes en
matière de protection des droits et
libertés unifier les deux contentieux au
profit du juge des libertés et de la
détention ne serait pas incohérent
toutefois une telle unification
risquerait d'alourdir l'ofice du juge
judiciaire et de le détourner alors
qu'il est appelé à statuer dans des
délais très contraints détourner de sa
mission qui est qui est d'apprécier la
proportionnalité de la privation de
liberté au regard de la situation
médicale du patient et je veux rappeler
que le surcroix de charge pour les
magistrats n'est pas un 20 mots nous
avons fait faire une étude alors les
choses ne sont pas pareilles est évident
dans toutes les juridictions mais les
juridictions dans les reessurs
desquelles il y a beaucoup d'hôpitaux
psychiatriques le travail est énorme par
exemple pour Paris les derniers chiffres
viennent de nous être
communiqués nous attendons
6522 affaires hein soit 25 affaires par
jour
supplémentaires c'est quelque chose qui
est particulièrement important ce qui
fait 25h de temps magistrat 12h3 de
temps d'audience et voit donc que le
poids que va avoir cette réforme sur une
juridiction comme celle de Paris celle
de Lyon est à peu près dans le même état
puisqu'il y a également trois hôpitaux
psychiatriques dans le ressort du
tribunal de grande instance de Lyon et
ensuite vous avez plusieurs tribunaux
qui ont un ou deux hôpitaux
psychiatriques dans leur ressort et je
pense à des petits
tribunaux où il y a à la fois un gros
établissement pénitentiaire et un
établissement psychiatrique important et
un magistrat qui est à la fois juge de
l'application des peines et juge des
libertés et de la détention C donc que
nous allons demander là un effort
extrêmement grand au magistrat un
concours exceptionnel de recrutement a
été
lancé vous pouvez concourir monsieur
ficher si vous voulez il existe il est
lancé donc il y a aucun problème on aura
des magistrats ils ne sont pas là le
1ier août cela est évident et c'est le
1er août et qu'il faudra donc mettre
cette réforme en œuvre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'objectif du
gouvernement est clair je crois qu'il
peut être partagé par tous c'est
renforcer les droits des personnes
faisant l'objet de soin psychiatrique et
permettre de mieux individualiser les
soins pour mieux répondre à chaque
situation que certains aspects du texte
méritent d'être amandés clarifiés cela
ne fait aucun doute pourquoi le
gouvernement vous proposera lui-même
d'ailleurs certains amendements en ce
qui concerne toutefois le rôle du juge
je tiens à renouveler mon appel à la
prudence et à l'équilibre il nous a
apptient de créer
exnilo une procédure entièrement
nouvelle la garantie des droits des
patients en sera considérablement
renforcé et la seule existence d'un
contrôle de plein droit du juge
entraînera de fait une diminution des
abus lorsqu'ils existent au nombre
desquels figurent notamment les sorties
d'écès qui furent fréquemment pendant
plusieurs années dans le cadre desquels
aucun suivi n'est garanti il s'agit
d'une véritable révolution je crains qu'
en la complexifiant outre mesure et en
faisant du juge ce qu'il n'est pas
c'est-àdire qu'il n'est ni médecin ni
préfet nous ne mettions en danger la
réforme elle-même qui s'imposera de
toute façon à tous au 1er août prochain
je voulais pour ma part simplement
aborder les questions plus strictement
juridiques du texte il appartient à
Madame nor ministre de la Santé de
d'aborder l'ensemble des autres
questions du texte je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur le garde des
saau la parole est maintenant à Madame
norura Berra secrétaire d'État chargée
de la
Santé avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente de la Commission des Affaires
social du Sénat monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
le texte que j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter aujourd'hui vise à réexaminer
certains points précis de la réforme des
soins psychiatriques c'est un texte qui
relève d'un domaine particulièrement
sensible non seulement sur le plan
médical et technique mais également
aussi j'en ai bien conscience sur le
plan humain je tiens d'abord à remercier
les memre de votre commission sa
présidente madame Dini votre rapporteur
monsieur Laurin pour le travail qu'ils
ont déjà effectué nous avons bien
entendu les interrogations et les
inquiétudes qui se sont exprimées en
commission nous entendons apporter au
cœur de ce débat toutes les réponses à
vos interrogations qui sont profondément
légitime le projet de loi que vous allez
examiner porte une réforme attendue
depuis une quinzaine d'années par les
professionnels de la psychiatrie mais
aussi par les patients et par leur
familles ce texte concerne les patients
qui trou qui souffrent de troubles
mentaux sévères ce qui rend impossible
leur consentement aux soins comme vous
le savez les troubles mentaux touchent
1/5e de la population française en 2008
1,3 millions de personnes adultes ont
ainsi été prises en charge danst 70 %
exclusivement en ambulatoire sur ce
total de personnes souffrant de maladie
mentale il y en a environ 70000 par an
dont les troubles rendent impossible
leur consentement aux soins ce qui
représente 5 % au total sur le total des
malades il me paraît important de
rappeler tout d'abord alors que s'ouvre
l'année des patients et de leurs droits
que toute atteinte à la leur liberté ne
peut être motivée que par des raisons
liées à leur état de santé comme le
rappelle Jean-Marie de la rue contre
leur général des lieux de privation de
liberté
je voudrais rappeler les raisons qui
nous conduisent à engager cette
réforme l'accueil des malades
psychiatriques selon des modalités
spécifiques et notamment quand ils ne
peuvent pas consentir aux soins a été
prévu dès 1838 par la loi obligeant tous
les départements de France à construire
un établissement spécialisé dans
l'accueil des malades psychiatriques
c'est pourquoi ces établissements sont
bien connus et identifiés par l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens il aura fallu
attendre 1990 pour réformer cette loi
pour prévoir que l'hospitalisation libre
soit la règle et pour que
l'hospitalisation sous contrainte
devienne une exception dûement motivée
et encadrée néanmoins cette loi de 1990
n'a pas résolu tous les problèmes comme
l'ont montré différents rapports elle ne
permet pas d'offrir aux malades qui ne
peuvent pas consentir au soins les
formes contemporaines de prise en charge
notamment
extraahospitalière elle n'a pas non plus
permis de résoudre le cas des personnes
qui doivent être hospitalisées mais pour
lesquells aucun proche ne peut en faire
la demande ce projet ne remet pas en
question les fondements de du dispositif
actuel qui permet une prise en charge
soit à la demande d'un tiers le plus
souvent un membre de la famille soit sur
décision du préfet mais ce projet de loi
comble les lacunes de la loi de de 1990
que je viens d'évoquer à savoir la prise
en charge ambulatoire ou la prise en
charge à la demande sans tiers sans
demande de tiers pour être plus précise
il comprend aussi des avancées
substantielles telles que l'intervention
du juge des libertés et de la détention
afin de répondre à la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel dans le cadre
d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité comme vient de le
rappel le garde des saut le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé le 26 novembre
dernier qu'en prévoyant que
l'hospitalisation sans consentement peut
être maintenue au-delà de 15 jours sans
intervention d'une juridiction de
l'ordre judiciaire les dispositions
relatives au maintien en hospitalisation
sur demande du tiers mais connaissent
les exigences de l'article 66 de la
Constitution le Conseil constitutionnel
nous don nous donne donc jusqu'au 1er
août pour corriger la loi actuelle l'un
des objectifs majeurs de ce texte
consiste à remplacer la notion
d'hospitalisation par celle de soins en
effet ce sont bien les soins qui sont
nécessaires pour un malade et non pas le
fait d'être placé dans un hôpital
psychiatrique ainsi il appartiendra au
médecin d'adapter précisément ses soins
aux besoins du malade en privilégiant
toujours la recherche d'une alliance
thérapeutique entre le patient et lui je
rappelle que les soins psychiatriques
peuvent suivre diverses modalités il
peut s'agir d'entretien d'atelier
thérapeutiques de traitements
médicamenteux que ces soins qui sont
souvent conjugués peuvent avoir lieu
dans des services hospitaliers fermés
mais aussi si l'état du patient le
permet au plus près de son lieu de vie
ce peut-être le centre
médico-psychologique le foyer la rue ou
la maison de retraite les médecins vous
le savez dans leur pratique quotidiennes
cherchent déjà à offrir des soins
ambulatoires aux patients qui ne peuvent
consentir à ces soins ils utilisent pour
cela le dispositif de la sortie d'essai
cependant la sortie d'essai telle que
prévue dans la loi de 1990 est un simple
essai de sortie après une longue
hospitalisation ce n'est donc pas une
forme de prise en charge il n'y a pas de
programme de soins définis il nous faut
donc combler cette lacune nous
souhaitons que les les médecins puissent
proposer à leurs malades un véritable
programme de soins à l'extérieur de
l'hôpital comme une forme de prise en
charge pleine et entière et non pas
comme un sas entre l'hospitalisation et
la vie ordinaire le texte permet ainsi
aux médecins de prescrire des soins
extérieurs dès le début de la prise en
charge c'est-à-dire à l'issue de la
période d'observation des 72 he sans
avoir besoin d'enclencher une longue
hospitalisation le médecin définira donc
avec son patient un programme de soins
ce que nous appelions jusqu'à présent le
protocole ce programme de soins
précisera le type de la prise en charge
les lieux de traitement et la
périodicité des soins cette avancée
majeure permettra donc de mieux définir
le rôle de
chacun le patient l'équipe soignante en
affirmant la place centrale du médecin
il restera le seul à même de modifier le
programme de soins du malade notre texte
rénove d'autres aspects de la loi de
1990 et met ainsi en œuvre les
préconisations des différents rapports
d'évaluation de cette loi c'est le cas
de la période d'observation et de soins
de 72 he que nous proposons d'instaurer
et qui est demandé par les
professionnels depuis le rapport stroll
de
1997 il s'agit d'éviter au maximum les
hospitalisations sans consentement en
apportant aux patients des soins
psychiatriques intensifs au moment de la
crise au bout de 3 jours les les
psychiatres parviennent bien souvent à
obtenir le consentement de la personne
elle va mieux comprend la nécessité de
poursuivre des soins et s'engage
d'elle-même dans une démarche
thérapeutique à l'hôpital ou en
ambulatoire notre période de 72 he donne
donc davantage de chance aux patients
d'éviter qu'une mesure de contrainte
trop longue soit enclenché à le rcontre
pour les patients dans le consentement
est encore trop fragile à l'issue de ces
3 jours qui peuvent être soignés à
l'extérieur mais qui ont besoin d'un
éteayage particulier le psychiatre
pourra désormais leur proposer une prise
en charge en ambulatoire avec un
programme de soins le projet de loi
apporte enfin une réponse au sujets
douloureux de personnes isolées qui ont
absolument besoin de soins
psychiatriques mais pour lesquels aucun
tiers ne se présente pour formuler une
demande les médecins les équipes
soignante nous le disent nombre de
personnes atteintes de maladies
psychiatriqu chronique ont perdu tout
lien avec leur famille et leurs proches
les psychiatres voudraient bien les
soigner mais sans demande formulée par
un tiers ils n'ont pas le droit de leur
porter secours ce qui est très pénible
pour un médecin les équipes passent
beaucoup de temps à rechercher ces tiers
et vous le
savez nous avons entendu les
professionnels et avons donc prévu que
le directeur de l'établissement puisse
prononcer l'admission d'un patient même
lorsqu'il n'est pas possible de
recueillir la demande d'un proche cette
possibilité est limité au seul cas de
péril imminant pour la santé du patient
et est entouré de garanties
particulières en terme de respect des
droits il s'agit d'une mesure
essentielle qui permettra à toutes les
personnes dans l'état de santé est très
grave quel que soit le leur tissu social
d'accéder aux soins psychiatriques de la
même façon nous rendons possible le fait
qu'un psychiatre s'oppose à la demande
de levée d'hospitalisation formulé par
un tiers il arrive en effet qu'une
personne soit hospitalisée sans son
consentement pour des troubles mentaux
graves mais que le directeur mette fin à
cette hospitalisation parce qu'un proche
du malade en a fait la demande en
application de ce projet de loi pour
éviter une rupture de soins qui serait
dangereuse pour le patient le psychiatre
pourra s'opposer à la demande de levée
de la mesure formulée par ce tiers
c'est donc bien l'accès aux soins la
continuité des soins psychiatriques que
le projet de loi renforce l'accès aux
soins sera également amélioré grâce à
une disposition introduite par
l'Assemblée nationale relative aux
personnes en situation d'urgence
psychiatrique vous connaissez bien ces
situations mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs lorsqu'une famille vous
appelle parce que son enfant est en
pleine crise psychiatrique qu'il faut
intervenir immédiatement qui intervient
qui transporte ce jeune vers l'établis
de santé certains territoires ont
imaginé des réponses coordonnées le
projet de loi impose que les acteurs
locaux hôpitaux SAMU 10 police
gendarmerie sous l'égide de l'Agence
Régionale de Santé définissent entre eux
une organisation adaptée afin de
répondre à toutes ces situations quel
que soit l'endroit du territoire de
santé où il faut intervenir le projet de
loi renforce donc les les droits et les
libertés des patients il a apporte aussi
un soin particulier à la situation de
certains patients atteints de troubles
très spécifiques pour lesquels les
dangers lié à une rechute apparaissent
plus sérieux il s'agit des patients qui
sont ou qui ont été hospitalisés
d'office soit pour
irresonsabilité pénale auteur de CRIM
mais dont le discernement était
totalement aboli au moment des faits
soit en unité pour malades
difficile l'Assemblée nationale a
souhaité prévoir que ses antécédents ne
soient pas rechercher sur la vie entière
du patient mais seulement sur une durée
qui sera fixée par décret en Conseil
d'État pour ces patients dont le nombre
est est extrêmement limité une procédure
particulière sera enclenchée lorsque
leur sortie est envisagée en effet la
vie du psychiatre traitant devra être
accompagné de l'avis d'un collège
pluridisciplinaire de soignant
psychologue infirmier assistant social
et de deux expertises le préfet
disposera ainsi d'information tout à
fait complète et étayée et pourra
incident de meilleures conditions
prendre cette décision qui est
particulièrement sérieuse j'insiste sur
le fait que pour ces patients comme pour
tous les autres les certificats
proposant des prises en charge
extraahospitalières ou des levés de
mesures devront être établis par un
psychiatre le psychiatre est la personne
centrale dans ce dispositif c'est le
psychiatre qui propose de lever
l'hospitalisation c'est le psychiatre
qui propose le programme de soins et qui
le définit et c'est le psychiatre qui
demande le cas échéant la
réhospitalisation ou la fin des soins
l'Assemblée nationale a d'ailleurs
confirmé ce rôle essentiel de psychiatre
en instaurant une saisine automatique du
juge des libertés de la détention si le
préfet ne donne pas suite à la demande
du psychiatre de mettre fin à
l'hospitalisation d'une personne enfin
vous le savez ce projet de loi vient
répondre à la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le bien fonderé des
hospitalisations complètes sans
consentement dès lors que leur durée
excède 15 jours puis 6 mois sera soumis
désormais au contrôle systématique du
juge des libertés et de la détention
dans ces intervalles et à tout moment je
le rappelle la personne peut recourir au
juge il s'agit du du recours facultatif
au moment où le patient en ressent la
nécessité la sisine automatique est une
mesure exceptionnelle elle porte sur une
priv de liberté d'aller et venir qui est
elle-même exceptionnelle le gouvernement
a fait le choix de ne pas prévoir cette
saisine automatique pour les autres
formes de prise en charge qui ont lieu
en ambulatoire en effet il importe tout
d'abord que la procédure soit plus
légère en extraahospitalier qu'en
intahospitalier sauf à décourager les
psychiatres à prescrire des soins à
l'extérieur dont on sait qu'ils sont
plus difficiles à organiser de plus le
patient suivi en ambulatoire est présumé
à mieux que le patient hospitalisé et
être davantage capable de saisir le juge
en cas de besoin je soulligne aussi que
ce juge le patient le connaîtra
puisqu'il l'aura rencontré au 15e jour
de son hospitalisation il sera donc plus
aisé pour le patient de le saisir à
nouveau d'autres personnes peuvent aussi
je le rappelle signaler au juges une
situation qui apparaîtrait à normale et
à la commission départementale des soins
psychiatriques continue d'être chargé de
vérifier les mesures qui apparaîtrai
disproportionnées en outre si les soins
apparaissent trop pesants pour ce
patient il est fort probable que
celui-ci aura rompu son programme de
soins et sera retourné en
hospitalisation complète où il verra
donc un juge sous 15 jours enfin et
surtout il serait incompréhensible pour
nombre de patients qu'on leur impose un
transport vers le juge alors qu'il
respectent leur programme de soins et
que tout se passe bien faudra-t-il aller
chercher chez les patients chez eux pour
les amener chez le juge la saisine une
automatique pour les patients qui ne
sont pas enfermés à
l'hôpital ne nous semble donc aller à
l'encontre du respect des droits et des
libertés de ces personnes sans apporter
de véritables garanties supplémentaires
en effet si le patient estime que son
programme de soins est excessif il doit
avant tout en parler avec son médecin et
l'équipe soignante qui le suit mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs ce projet de
loi sur lequel vous allez vous pencher
aujourd'hui est essentiel tout d'abord
pour permettre à tous les malades un
meilleur accès aux soins la psychiatrie
française peut dés désormais franchir le
pas qu'on franchit ses voisins européens
elle peut résolument se tourner comme
l'ont fait la chirurgie ou la médecine
vers la prise en charge ambulatoire pour
l'ensemble des personnes qui en ont
besoin elle peut offrir à tous des
formes de soins psychiatriques modernes
dans tous les lieux de la cité des soins
qui permettent aux patients de rester au
maximum insérés dans leur communauté la
psychiatrie française peut leur offrir
cette qualité des soins elle a été l'une
des premières à s'ouvrir vers
l'extérieur avec la politique de secteur
le projet de loi s'inscrit dans
l'évolution que les psychiatres ont
eux-mêmes donné à leur pratique le
projet de loi apporte des garanties
supplémentaires pour l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés en mettant au cœur du
dispositif le psychiatre et l'équipe
soignante les qu vise un seul but
l'accès au soins la continuité de ces
soins l'alliance thérapeutique la
protection des personnes et le respect
des libertés je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est maintenant à monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
notre collègue Jean-Louis
Laurin
avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est particulièrement
important car il concerne la situation
des personnes parmi les plus fragiles
celles qui souffrent de troubles mentaux
lorsqu'on aborde ce sujet nous devons
avoir à l'esprit trois impératifs
essentiel qu'il nous faut concilier la
nécessité de donner au malade les
meilleurs soins possibles afin de
favoriser sa guérison ou au moins
l'amélioration de son état de
santé l'obligation de ne limiter la
liberté des personnes que dans des
proportions strictement nécessaire pour
éviter qu'elle ne nuise à elle-même ou
qu'elle nuise à
autrui enfin la préservation de la
sécurité des personnes parfois menacé
par le comportement de certains malades
une réforme de la loi de 1990 est
attendue depuis longtemps et elle a été
préconisée par de nombreux rapports
depuis 97 dont le texte qui nous est
soumis reprend de nombreuses
propositions au moment de débuter cette
discussion je souhaite saluer le travail
accompli par Madame diny en qualité de
rapporteur ce travail important et
approfondi a permis à chacun de nous de
faire mûir sa position pour rechercher
tout ensemble les moyens de construire
une réforme équilibrée et je me sens
monsieur ficher mon rapporteur à temps
plein mais pleinement responsable qui
entend aussi habiter complètement ce
domaine qui est aussi le mien depuis une
trentaine d'années en tant qu'élu
concerné dès à présent il me faut
souligner que cette loi serait vaine si
elle n'était pas accompagné des moyens
nécessaires pour la mettre en œuvre et
de mesures ambitieuses pour pour
l'organisation de la psychiatrie de la
santé mentale dans notre pays madame la
ministre nous entendons avec impatience
le plan de santé mentale que vous êtes
en train de préparer nous espérons qu'il
répondra aux attentes des malades et de
leurs familles ainsi qu'à celle de tous
les intervenants en
psychiatrie ce plan est nécessaire et
urgent il est le complément
indispensable du projet de loi dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui alors quels sont
les principales disposition du texte en
premier lieu le projet se donne pour
objectif de diversifier les formes de
prise en charge des malade faisant
l'objet de soins psychiatriques sans
leur consentement alors qu'actuellement
une personne ne peut faire l'objet de
soins psychiatriques sans son
consentement que sous la forme d'une
hospitalisation complète le projet de
loi tend à dissocier le principe de
l'obligation des soins et les modalités
de dispensation de ces soins un régime
de soins sans consentement est ainsi
substitué au régime de l'hospitalisation
sans consentement alors les modes de
prise en charge alternatif à
l'hospitalisation complète incluraient
obligatoirement des soins ambulatoire il
pourrait également prendre la forme de
soins à domicile ou de séjour effectués
dans un établissement psychiatrique en
cas de soins psychiatrique sans
consentement sous une autre forme que
l'hospit ation complète un protocole de
soins serait établi dans les 72 he de
l'admission du malade par le psychiatre
de
l'établissement ce protocole définirait
le ou les types de soins imposés aux
malades les lieux de leur réalisation
ainsi que leur périodicité dans tous les
cas la prise en charge d'un malade sans
son consentement débuterait par une
période d'observation et de soins de 72
he sous forme d'une hospitalisation
complète au cours de cette période deux
certificats médicaux devrai évaluer la
nécessité de la mesure de soins sans
consentement le premier serait établi
dans les 24 heures suivant l'admission
et le 2 dans les 72
he le texte prévoit que lorsque le
certificat conclut à la nécessité de
prolonger les soins un psychiatre de
l'établissement propose dans un avis
motivé
la forme de prise en charge du malade
ainsi que s'il envisage une forme de
prise en charge alternative à
l'hospitalisation complète le protocole
de soins
applicable en cas d'admission à la
demande d'un tiers le directeur de
l'établissement aurait compéten pour
retenir la forme de prise en charge
proposée par le psychiatre ainsi que le
protocole de soins établi par
celui-ci en cas d'admission sur décision
du représentant de l'État le préfet
aurait compétence pour décider de la
forme de prise en charge en tenant
compte de la proposition établie par le
psychiatre et des exigences liées à la
sûreté des personnes et à l'ordre
public en deuxième lieu pour tenir
compte de la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel le projet de loi modifie
les conditions dans lesquelles le juge
des libertés et de la détention
contrôlera les mesures de soin sans
consentement la saisine du juge est
prévue dans deux cas soit comme
actuellement à l'initiative de la
personne faisant l'objet d'une mesure de
soin sans consentement ou d'autres
personnes intéressées au fin d'ordonner
la levée de cette mesure de façon
obligatoire aussi à l'initiative du
directeur de l'établissement ou du
préfet auin de contrôler de plein droit
nécessité du maintien de toute mesure de
soin sans consentement prenant la forme
d'une hospitalisation
complète le juge devrait obligatoirement
statuer sur l'hospitalisation sans
consentement d'une personne avant
l'expiration d'un délai de 15 jours à
compté de son admission en soin sans
consentement sous forme d'une
hospitalisation complète puis tous les 6
mois lorsque le patient est maintenu en
hospitalisation
le texte prévoit que le juge statut
après débat contradictoire et que
l'audience peut avoir lieu en utilisant
la technique de la
visioconférence les ordonnances du juge
pourrai faire l'objet d'un appel devant
le premier président de la cour d'appel
ou son délégué et cet appel pourrait
revêtir un caractère suspensif si le
juge ordonnait la mainlevée de
l'hospitalisation
par ailleurs l'Assemblée nationale a
prévu une saisine obligatoire du juge de
libertés lorsque le préfet refuse de
faire droit à une demande de levere de
soins psychiatriqu émanant du
psychiatre en troisième lieu le projet
de loi met en place des procédures
particulières pour la sortie des soins
sans consentement des personnes ayant
été déclaré pénalement irresponsabl ou
ayant fait un séjour unifié dans les
malad pour dans les dans des secteurs
pour malades difficiles dit
UMD l'article 1er prévoit la création
d'un collège de soignants composé de
trois membres appartenants au personnel
de l'établissement un psychiatre
participant à la prise en charge du
patient un psychiatre n'y participant
pas et enfin un membre de l'équipe
pleuridisciplinaire ce collège devrait
se prononcer avant la levée des soins
sans consentement des personnes
concernées en outre deux expertises
devraient obligatoirement être réalisé
par des psychiatres extérieurs à
l'établissement d'accueil l'Assemblée
nationale a complété ce dispositif pour
prévoir qu'il ne s'applique plus après
une certaine durée dont la fixation est
renvoyée à un décret en Conseil d'État
enfin le projet de loi contient
plusieurs autres mesures d'importance il
cré
une nouvelle procédure
d'hospitalisation en cas de péril
imminent qui pourrait être réalisé sans
demande d'un tiers cette nouvelle voie
d'accès aux soins pourrait notamment
concerner les personnes isolées elle
pourrait également être utilisé dans des
situations où la demande
d'hospitalisation est particulièrement
difficile à formuler pour les membres de
la
famille le projet aussi renforce
le droit à l'information des personnes
recevant des soins sans leur
consentement il procède à une réécriture
des dispositifs du Code de Santé
publique relative à l'hospitalisation
sans consentement des détenus sans
toutfis en modifier le
contenu les autres dispositions du
projet de loi sont de moindre importance
et visent à opérer des coordination ou à
prévoir l'application ou en areemre du
projet de
loi
mes chers collègues ce projet de loi
n'est certainement pas parfait mais il
me semble que notre travail est
précisément de rechercher les moyens de
l'améliorer de renforcer sa cohérence et
C cet exercice que nous devons essayer
d'accomplir ensemble ce matin notre
commission a donné de nombreux avis à
des amendements et ces avis ne sont pas
tous compatibles entre eux sur le point
le plus délicat de ce texte les soins en
psychiatrique sans consensement hors de
l'hôpital je comprends parfaitement
toutes les objections qui peuvent être
soulevées le choix de cette expression
paraît d'ailleurs contradictoire dans
les termes mais il me semble que nous
pouvons rechercher les voies et les
moyens d'une amélioration plus plutôt
que de renvoyer à plus tard
l'introduction de ce de ce concept vous
savez mes chers collègues que sans
l'intervention du conseil instutionnel
nous n'aurions probablement pas été
saisis de ce texte donc je crois qu'il
faut profiter de l'occasion qui nous est
donnée pour accomplir un travail de
modernisation de la psychiatrie qui est
attendu depuis longtemps et en C début
de 21e siècle il normal que les modes de
prise en charge des patients évoluent il
est souhaitable qu'ell puissent être
accompagné dans leur milieu habituel
lorsqu'on peut éviter
l'hospitalisation alors si nous
renvoyons cela à plus tard
nous risquons de ne jamais faire ce
travail notre collègue à la mon a
présenté un amendement tout à fait utile
qui clarifie des points importants cet
amendement précise tout d'abord qu'une
personne faisant l'objet de soins sans
son consentement est prise en charge par
tous les outils thérapeutiques de la
psychiatrie adapté à son état et j'y
souscris il fait référence non plus à
des formes de soins mais à des lieux de
soins et j'y souscris en distingant les
unités d'hospitalisation temps plein des
autres lieux de soins que sont les
unités alternatives à l'hospitalisation
temps plein les lieux de consultation
les lieux d'activité thérapeutiques les
lieux de vie habituel du patient et j'y
ajouterai même la
rue enfin il remplace la notion de
protocole de soin par celle de programme
de soins ce qui me paraît beaucoup plus
adapté car la notion de protocole
apparaît un peu trop rigide alors à
titre personnel
je vous proposerai et ce sera l'exercice
qui sera le mien l'amendement de
monsieur mon pour apporter de nouvelles
précisions et des compléments d'abord je
crois très profondément qu'il ne
faudrait plus parler de soins sans
consentement mais de soins
psychiatriques auxquels une personne
n'est pas à même de consentir du fait de
ses troubles mentaux et je crois que
c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est pour moi important le soin c'est le
dialogue mais pourquoi la confusion
vient du fait de la nécessité de
l'obligation et de la modalité alors ce
changement marque mieux qu'il faut
distinguer entre donc l'obligation qui
est faite au patient de se soigner ce
qui est important mais les modalités de
soin qui seront ell bien sûr discuté
entre le psychiatre et le malade en
outre je vous proposerai de mieux
préciser les conditions de modification
du programme de soin et de prévoir un
entretien entre le psychiatre et le
malade au cours duquel le médecin
recueillera l' vie du patient enfin le
sous-amendement que j'ai préparé prévoit
aussi que le détail des traitements
médicamenteamenteux ne figureront pas
sur le programme de soins en début
j'espère que c nouvelle rédaction
apaisera les inquiétudes et qu'elle
permettra d'avancer dans la recherche
d'un vrai consensus sur cette réforme
sur les autres dispositions du projet de
loi des améliorations sont encore
possibles ainsi la commission a donné un
avis favorable à un amendement qui
modifie la composition du collège chargé
de donner un avis avant la levée
d'hospital d'hospitalisation des
patients ayant séjourné en UMD ou ayant
fait l'objet d'une déclaration
d'irresponsabilité pénal il paraît
préférable que l'ensemble de l'équipe
pluriprofessionnelle soit dans ce ce
collège pour certains plutôt que l'un de
ses membres ceci serend encore bien sûr
à discuter pour mais le souci est
d'assurer une véritable
collégialité de même notre Commission a
accepté des amendements qui fixe à 10
ans le délai de droit à l'oubli à partir
duquel la procédure d'examen renforcé
n'est plus applicable aux patients qui
ont été déclarés irresponsables ou
séjourné en UMD monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je forme le souhait que nos débat
permett de faire progresser la réflexion
de dégager des solutions attendues
notamment pour les malades et leurs
familles je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur mainant donner la parole à
Monsieur Jean-René leerf rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des
lois
avez la parole monsieur
rapporte monsieur président monsieur le
ministre de la Justice garde des saau
ministre de justice et des libertés
chers
collègues notre assemblée est saisie du
projet de loi déposé le 5 mai 2010 à
l'Assemblée nationale relatif au droit
et la protection des personnes faisant
l'objet de soins psychiatrique et au
modalités de leur prise en charge
ce projet de loi a été complété par une
lettre rectificative du 26 janvier 2011
qui tire les conséquences de la décision
du Conseil constitutionnelle du 26
novembre 2010 prise dans le cadre d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité sur renvoi du Conseil
d'État dans cette décision le Conseil
constitutionnel a distingué les
conditions d'admission et le maintien de
l'hospitalisation sans consentement en
ce qui concerne les conditions
d'admission il les a estimé confor la
Constitution dès lors que si l'article
66 de cette Constitution exige que toute
privation de liberté individuelle soit
placé sous le contrôle de l'autorité
judiciaire il n'impose pas que cette
dernière soit saisie préalablement à
toute mesure de privation de
liberté en ce qui concerne le maintien
de
l'hospitalisation le Conseil
constitutionnel avait à se prononcer sur
la question
suivante le rôle de l'autorité
judiciaire gardienne de la liberté
individu
impose-il qu'au-delà d'une certaine
durée le maintien de la privation de
liberté ne puisse se faire sans une
décision de l'autorité judiciaire il y a
répondu par
l'affirmative rappelant les exigences
constitutionnelles selon lesquelles la
liberté individuelle ne peut être tenue
pour sauvegarder que si le juge
judiciaire intervient dans le plus court
délai possible et exigeant un contrôle
juridictionnel de plein droit des
décisions de maintien en hospitalisation
sans consentement dès lors il s'est posé
deux questions de
délai sur le délai dans lequel une
intervention de l'autorité judiciaire
est exigée le Conseil constitutionnel a
estimé que le délai de 48 he applicable
en matière de garde à vue n'était pas
transposable à l'hospitalisation sans
consentement prenant en compte la
spécificité de la problématique médicale
il a fixé ce délai à 15 jours sur le
délai dans lequel juge judiciaire doit
statuer le Conseil constitutionnel a
formulé une réserve d'interprétation
pour imposer les plus breèves délaiis
enfin considérons qu'une abrogation
immédiate des dispositions du Code de la
santé publique jugée inconstitutionnel
entraînerait des conséquences
manifestement excessives au regard des
exigences de la protection de la liber
de la santé et de prévention des
atteintes à l'ordre public il a reporté
au 1er août 2011 la date de mise en
conformité avec la Constitution dans une
certaine mesure mes chers collègues et
sans chger sans chercher un mauvais jeu
de mot nous délibérons nous aussi sous
la
contrainte devant l'étroite imbrication
des Conseil constitutionnel on a décidé
ainsi après tout les questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité sont
quand même un acquis considérable en
matière de liberté devant l'étroite
imbrication des questions de santé et
des questions juridiques votre
commission des Lois a souhaité se saisir
pour avis ce qui n'avait pas a été fait
à l'Assemblée nationale se saisir pour
avis du volet judiciaire du texte qui
relève essentiellement des articles 1 à
5 la commission des affaires sociales
ayant été bien sûr et naturellement
saisie au fond cette saisie nous est
apparue nécessaire en raison des
nombreux points qui intéressent
directement le champ de compétence de la
commission des lois les libertés
individuelles et les garanties
juridictionnelles qui s'attachent à leur
privation les modalités de contrôle de
l'autorité judiciaire visionférence dél
d'intervention possibilité d'appel
suspensif l'impact de la réforme sur
l'organisation judiciaire la répartition
des compétences entre les deux ordres de
juridiction ou la protection de l'ordre
public je profite mes chers collègues de
le l'opportunité qui m'est offerte pour
regretter que sur de nombreux textes
récemment examinés par le Parlement il
n'y ait pas eu plus souvent
d'appréhension qui soit une appréhension
partagée entre la justice et la santé je
pense par exemple à la loi pénit cière
ce qui n'a pas permis d'examiner à fond
les problèmes relatifs à la santé santé
somatique mais également santé
psychiatrique je pense aussi à une
proposition de loi que j'avais déposé
sur la responsabilité pénale des malades
mentaux et qui était rapporté par mon
collègue Jean-Pierre Michel qui a été
adopté à l'unanimité par le Sénat et qui
finira bien un jour par être examiné par
l'Assemblée national l'hospitalisation
sous contrainte est régie vous le savez
par un droit ancien et stable
puisque c'est la loi esquirole de 1838
qui a distingué le régime du placement
volontaire à la demande de la famille et
le régime du placement d'office confié
au préfet que cette loi n'a été modifiée
qu'en 1981 par la loi sécurité et
liberté puis surtout en 1990 par la loi
evv1 celle-ci a certes consacré le droit
des personnes hospitalisées contre leur
Gret mais elle a conservé les deux modes
d'hospitalisation sans consentement
prévu par la loi de 1838 le placement
d'office est remplacé par
l'hospitalisation d'office et le
placement volontaire cède la place à
l'hospitalisation à la demande d'un
tiers actuellement notre pays compte
80000 hospitalisations contraintes
chaque année pour des cas de
schizophrénie dans la moitié des cas
63000 à la demande d'un tiers et 17000
d'office le projet de loi réforme le
droit de l'hospitalisation sous
contrainte en cherchant à concilier
trois principes de même valeur mais qui
sont parfois largement antagonistes le
droit à la protection de la santé la
sécurité des personnes les libertés
individuelles il ouvre une alternative à
l'hospitalisation complète en faisant de
l'enfermement une modalité de soin parmi
d'autres l'objectif est d'adapter la loi
à l'évolution des soins psychiatriques
et des thérapeutique désormais disponibl
qui permettent à de nombreux patients
d'être pris en charge par des soins
ambulatoires c'est-à-dire extra
hospitalier
encadré comme de nombreux collègues de
la commission des lois je suis plutôt
favorable à l'extension des soins
ambulatoires sous contrainte tout en
rappelant qu'ils exigeront des moyens
adaptés le dispositif si fréquemment
critiqué de la sortie d'essai est
supprimé les personnes internées sous
contrainte seront placées en observation
pour 72 he maximum en hospitalisation
complète deux certificats médicaux de
psychiatre devront alors établir s'il
faut poursuivre les soins et leur nature
le projet de loi choisit de ne pas
recourir systématiquement au juges
judiciire pour les soins ambulatoires
sous contrainte l'intervention du juge
est donc obligatoire pour
l'hospitalisation complète mais
facultative pour les soins ambulatoires
il prévoit un dispositif spécifique
applicable à certaines personnes
susceptibles d'actes graves de violence
celles qui ont été reconnues pénalement
irresponsables et qui font ou ont fait
l'objet d'une hospitalisation d'office
judiciaire celles qui font ou ont fait
l'objet d'une hospitalisation en UMD
unité pour malade difficile dans ces cas
les sorties seront plus encadrées le
juge des libertés et de la détention
devra recueillir l'avis d'un collège de
soignant et s'il envisage la mainlevée
de l'hospitalisation complète ordonner
une expertise judiciaire supplémentaire
enfin le préfet ne pourra mettre fin à
l'hospitalisation d'office judiciaire
qu'après avis d'un collège de soignants
et de avis concordant sur l'état médical
du patient émis par deux psychiatres
étrangers à l'établissement
d'hospitalisation enfin ce texte encadre
la notion de tiers susceptible de
solliciter une hospitalisation
contrainte en contrepartie il crée une
nouvelle procédure l'admission stière en
cas de péril imminent s'agissant des
conséquences sur l'organisation
judiciaire l'étude d'impact évalue le
nombre de saisines nouvelles à 61000
pour les juges de liberté et de la
détention
et les besoins d'emploi entre 77 et 80
magistrats 59 et 61 fonctionnaires 59 à
61 fonctionnaires de catégorie B et 7 à
8 fonctionnaires de catégorie C enfin le
texte prévoit que l'audience du JLD
pourra s'effectué par visioconférence
dans des locaux adaptés de l'hôpital les
députés ont apporté plusieurs
modifications ils ont introduit un droit
à l'oubli c'est-à-dire un retour au
droit commun pour les deux catégories de
patients susceptibles de présenter un
danger pour autrui passer un délai de
plusieurs années après la fin de leur
hospitalisation l'Assemblée nationale a
prévu une saisine automatique du JLD par
le directeur de l'établissement
d'accueil du patient lorsque le préfet
n'ordonne pas la levée de
l'hospitalisation complète alors que le
psychiatre estime que cette
hospitalisation n'est plus nécessaire
elle a également prévu que lorsque le
JLD ordonne la main levée d'une mesure
d'hospitalisation complète sa décision
prend effet dans un délai de 48 he à
afin que le psychiatre de
l'établissement puisse le cas échéant
établir un protocole de soin et que le
patient puisse recevoir un traitement
contraint sous forme de soin ambulatoire
nous nous interrogeons cependant en
commission des lois sur la
constitutionnalité de cette situation
puisqu'une personne demeurera contrainte
pendant 48 he alors que la décision de
mainlevée aura été
prononcée je vous proposerai au nom de
la commission des lois d'étendre
quelques que peut la compétence du juge
judiciaire gardien des libertés
individuelles en le dotant d'une
capacité de transformer une mesure
d'hospitalisation complète en soit
ambulatoire je sais que sur ce point
monsieur le ministre n'est pas du même
avis j'espère que nous aurons l'occasion
d'échanger nos arguments et de trouver
peut-être effectivement une solution
consensuelle en prévoyant également le
contrôle de plein droit du JLD sur les
mesures d'hospitalisation partielle sous
contrainte enfin en unifiant le
contentieux de l'hospitalisation sous
contrainte par par la création d'un bloc
de compét judiciaire je vous proposerai
également de permettre que le juge
statut dans des conditions garantissant
la sérénité des débat en prévoyant qu'il
pourra statuer en chambre du conseil et
non publiquement mais aussi que la
visioconférence sera adaptée à la
situation des personnes malades et j'ai
bien entendu effectivement l'accord de
monsieur le ministre sur ce point enfin
je vous proposeraiis d'envisager
l'évolution peut-être à terme du statut
de l'infirmerie psychiatrique de la
préfecture de police de Paris monsieur
leés Président mes chers collègues le
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté dans un rapport
d'activité pour 2010 qui vient de sortir
a fait observer que dans les
établissements de santé se pose avec
acuité la question de l'équilibre entre
les droits des personnes les exigences
du soins et les nécessités de sécurité
indispensables il note je le cite que
cet équilibre n'est pas souvent réalisé
de manière satisfaisante aujourd'hui
j'espère que ce projet de loi marquera
un progrès significatif sur cette
question particulièrement sensible je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur nous allons poursuivre notre
discussion en général et la parole est à
notre collègue Jacques mzard pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
social et
européen très
bien la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre garde des
saau mes chers collègues la maladie
mentale c'est un drame du quotidien que
nous connaissons un drame pour des
centaines de milliers de familles et ce
drame justifie
pleinement de lever nombre de tabou et
surtout de trouver des
moyens maladie soins contrainte et
liberté quel équilibre difficile or ce
complexifie les procédures à tel point
que je me suis demandé s'il ne relevait
pas d'une pathologie juridique
c'est-à-dire d'une coupure de l'esprit
au sens d'une perte de contact avec la
réalité il suffit de se reporter au
problème de la visioconférence à la
multiplication des certificats médicaux
et àant d'autres exemples pour s'en
convaincre plus de règles moins de droit
or ce projet de loi s'intitule droit et
protection des personnes faisant l'objet
de soins psychiatriques il devrait donc
avoir pour objectif fondamental les
malades et ceux qui les soignent sans
être viciés par le volet sécuritaire et
sa déclinaison médiatique ce d'autant
plus suite à l'introduction inadéquate
et je reprends les propos du rapporteur
indiquant que sans la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel ce texte ne
serait pas venu devant nous
et malheureusement de ce choc de
priorités antagonistes est né un texte
qui a le privilège au mauvais sens du
terme d'être rejeté tant par la majorité
des psychiatres des hôpitaux que par les
syndicats de magistrats et l'examen
chaotique en commission des affaires
sociales est révélateur de ce rejet
alors que les troubles mentaux se
classent aujourd'hui au 3e rang des
maladies en terme de de prévalence la
véritable urgence nous le savons tous
c'est de lutter contre cet état
catastrophique de ce secteur de santé et
le manque dramatique de médecins
psychiatres en particulier dans les
hôpitaux déjà en 2008 la Commission
nationale des Droits de l'Homme avait
déploré que la question de la maladie
mentale a été évoquée dans le débat
publicque à propos de textes qui ont
alimenté l'amalgame et la confusion avec
la délinquence la violence et la
dangerosité j'avais dà déjà eu
l'occasion de souligner cet amalgame
dangereux entre trouble psychiatrique et
dangerosité lors de l'examen de la
proposition de loi relative à
l'atténuation de responsabilité pénale
en cas de trouble mental dans ce projet
de loi la décision prise sans le
consentement de l'intéressé consacre
dorénavant l'entrée dans une phase
d'obligation de de soins dont
l'hospitalisation ne sera désormais
qu'une des modalités possibles et qui
pourra recouvrir des soins ambulatoire
sans
consentement la dérogation au droit de
tout malade de consentir aux soins dont
il fait l'objet ouvre un champ inédit
dans la mesure où la contrainte pourra
être exercée entre les murs de
l'établissement mais également hors les
murs sans accroche territoriale ce qui
rend plus difficile tout ôle de la
nécessité ou de la proportionnalité des
mesures prises ainsi que la sortie de
cette situation
d'exception si ce contrôle par le juge
des libertés tel qu'il découle de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel nous
semble pleinement correspondre à la
mission de garantie des libertés
individuelles que le juge doit exercer
conformément à la Constitution il est
impératif de mettre en place les moyens
nécessaires en terme d'effectif et de
formation nous avons entendu les
inquiétudes et mises en garde des
professionnels il apparaît clairement
que de nombreuses dispositions de ce
texte sont inapplicables et dangereuses
en ce qui concerne le transfert de
l'ensemble des contentieux vers
l'autorité judiciaire des septembre 2012
or la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel est
contraignante si le ministère a annoncé
le recrutement d'effectifs
supplémentaires ceuxci n'arriveront en
juridiction malheureusement au mieux
qu'un an après l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi et nous savons que il y aura
manifestement un engorgement des
contentieux une asphyxie des
juridictions de l'ordre judiciaire
d'autres dispositions du projet de loi
nous apparaissent inopportunes les
prescriptions médicales pour les soins
ambulatoires doivent demeurer
déontologiquement indépendantes il
serait dangereux d'instaurer une
discrimination par des procédures
spécifiques supplémentaires et puis ce
texte mes chers collègues complique
considérablement les procédures par
l'entretien et le développement d'une
dualité juridictionnelle avec une
prépondérance laissé à l'administratif
au préfet au directeurs d'hôpitaux on se
demande pourquoi vous n'y avez pas
ajouté le citoyen assesseurs ça viendra
de plus les psychiatres hospitaliers
monsieur le ministre doivent être
garantis dans leur indépendance
professionnelle face à un tel dispositif
qui multiplie et soumet les certificats
médicaux aux instances administratives
il faut qu'il retrouve une nomination
spécifique ministérielle indépendante
des pouvoirs administratifs locaux
indépendance qui leur a été
sournoisement retiré par le décret
statutaire d'octobre 2010 et qui est
l'indispensable garant des libertés
individuelles dans le domaine de
l'hospitalisation sous contrainte pour
conclure nous souhaitons nous qu'il soit
ce texte soit limité temporairement aux
modifications de la législation actuelle
découlant de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel afin que nous prenions
le temps d'élaborer dans la concertation
avec tous les acteurs une réforme
vraiment adaptée un tel dossier
mériterait plus que d'autres un
consensus profond et nous attendons
toujours nous attendons
toujours un grand plan santé mentale
équivalent au plan cancer ou au plan
Alzheimer qui fasse enfin de la santé
mentale un objectif prioritaire de santé
publique pour nous ce texte ne répond
pas à cet objectif et c'est pourquoi
majoritairement nous ne le voterons
pas merci mon cher collègue la parole
est au président gu ficher pour le
groupe crcspg pour 15
minutes
monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il y a tout juste un an notre
groupe organisait au Sénat un colloque
intitulé psychiatrie
entre pression sécuritaire et
contraintes économique quelle place pour
le
patient la richesse des débats que nous
avions eu à alors m'autorise à affirmer
ceci le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui n'est pas le texte
qu'attendaient les malades et leurs
familles le texte qu'attendaient les
médecins le texte qu'attendai les
magistrats le texte que nous
attendions initié en novembre 2008 à la
suite d'un fait d'hiver certes tragique
survenu à saintgrève dans l'Isère selon
la méthode habituelle de notre président
consistant à jouer sur l'émotion et les
peurs ce texte porte tous les attribut
des lois émotionnelles des lois
d'affichage il laisse de côté toutes les
questions qu'un vrai projet de loi sur
la psychiatrie et la santé mentale
aurait dû aborder pour ne conserver
qu'une vision limitée
étriqué borné de l'accompagnement des
personnes souffrant de troubl
psychiatrique il ulte en effet plusieurs
faits
essentiels si les questions liées au
troubles mentaux sont complexes si nous
ne pouvons taire les difficultés que
rencontre soignant magistrat proche
malad et si les pouvoirs publics
particulièrement les maires peuvent
parfois se sentir démunis il convient de
rappeler quelques évidences mes chers
collègues seul 2,7 % des actes violents
sont commis par des personnes souffrant
de troubles psychiatriques selon le
rapport de liigaz de 2005 notre collègue
Guy lefran député UMP le dit lui-même en
préambule de son rapport les personnes
atteintes de troubles psychiatriques
sont 12 fois plus victimes d'agression
physique 130 fois plus victimes de vol
et ont 25 ans d'espérance de vie en
moins que nos concitoyens à ces réalités
crues démontrant que ces personnes sont
d'abord et souvent des victimes s'ajoute
une autre réalité celle de la mise à mal
de la psychiatrie publique avec pour
seul exemple 40000 lit supprimé en 20
ans si l'on ajoute à cela les
suppressions de postes le recul de la
sectorisation l'abandon de la prévention
les personnes les plus malades échappent
aux soins désormais c'est la lutte des
places en hôpital psychiatrique public
me disait un président de CME ce texte
est-il à la hauteur de ce que nous
devons à cette population évidemment non
mes chers collègues vous avez compris
que nous pensons que ce texte
sécuritaire va totalement à l'encontre
de ce qu'il faudrait attendre en terme
d'ambition flou
imprécis opportuniste pour notre part ce
sont les raisons de qui nous avait
conduit malgré certaines avancées
réelles introduites par notre rapporteur
mugaddini à rejeter ce texte en
commission le gouvernement avait
pourtant annoncé la couleur on nous
parlait d'un triple objectif un objectif
de santé un objectif de défense des
libertés individuelles et enfin un
objectif de sécurité disons-le
clairement en ce qui concerne l'objectif
de santé nous ne voyons rien rien en
faveur d'une meilleure prise en charge
des malades rien sur l'ambition de
redonner à tous les acteurs du monde
psychiatrique soignants malades familles
magistrats les moyens de soigner et
d'accompagner l'étude d'impact reste
sinon très optimiste à tout le moins
parfaitement irréaliste surtout dans le
contexte de la réduction général des
politiques publiques ce qu'elle
préconise en terme de moyens ce n'est ni
plus ni moins qu'un pansement sur une
jambe de bois en l'espèce c'est d'une
politique cohérente et d'un sauvetage
massif qu'a besoin la médecine
psychiatrique française le pire c'est
que nous savons tous ce qui est
nécessaire plus de postes plus de lit
pour un meilleur suivi à l'hôpital ou en
dehors oui cela mériterait certainement
autre chose qu'un jugement de courte vue
initié par une politique opportune
oui l'objectif de santé n'est clairement
pas satisfait j'en veux pour preuve
supplémentaire le titre 2 intitulé suivi
des malades sur toutes ces dispositions
il n'est question que de l'encadrement
du soin sans consentement rien sur les
objectifs de traitement par ailleurs
nous nous interrogeons sur la pertinence
même du terme soin sans consentement
surtout que nous savons qu' matière
psychiatrique en particulier l'absence
de consentement du malade est souvent
une des causes de l'échec du traitement
écoutez la vie du docteur Roger Ferreri
chef de service dans les sones on
mélange tout la contrainte n'est pas du
soin c'est une décision de la société la
société a le droit de se protéger mais
lorsque vous mettez quelqu'un dans une
chambre d'isolement vous n'avez pas le
droit de penser que c'est pour son bien
mais ce texte visil véritablement le
traitement des malades c'est bien ce qui
nous conduit à douter de l'objectif
sanitaire du texte à l'évidence le corps
du projet de loi est bien l'objectif
sécuritaire l'ordre public serait menacé
par ces personnes en souffrance quel
curieuse conception de la maladie
psychiatrique qui consiste à considérer
des patients comme des fauteurs de
trouple en puissance plus que des malade
de toute évidence pourtant la logique
sécuritaire du texte nécessite
l'internement ou la contrainte tout en
limitant les droits des personnes
souffrant de troubles mentaux découlent
de cette conception fondamentale de la
maladie mentale comme initi initiatrice
de trouble à l'ordre public de notre
point de vue la simple considération de
la prise en charge des personnes
atteintes de troubles psychiatriques
sous langue sécuritaire et vous l'avez
compris non seulement réductrice mais
inaccepttable
l'intervention du préfet trouve sa place
dans la ligne droite de cette conception
sous le motif du trouble à l'ordre
public sont batttu en brèche beaucoup de
nos principes qui gouvernent les
libertés individuelles des personnes nos
libertés
individuelles par exemple la mesure qui
consiste en la création d'une période de
72 heures d'observation en
hospitalisation complète s'apparant
s'apparentant à une véritable garde à
vue psychiatrique la mesure est à la
fois inapplicable par son immense flou
et plus encore profondément contraire à
nos principes en termees de libertés
individuelles on peut effectivement se
poser la question de l'opportunité d'une
telle mesure alors que le régime de la
garde à vue a précisément été révisé
pour en atténuer les abus en effet cette
mesure n'a aucune différence de forme
avec une garde à vue elle est aussi
arbitraire et par définition aussi
Privat de liberté les garanties qui
entourent cette période d'observation
sont selon nous bien trop FAI pour
atténuer le pouvoir du préfet comment
imaginer qu'une telle période de 72 he
puisse être décidée par le préfet selon
le motif flou du péril imminent comment
imaginer comment accepter que le préfet
puisse être quasiment le seul à en juger
le médecin ne servant là qu' d'
auxiliaire de police vos texte n'est pas
assez clair sur les garanties qui
entourent cette notion et nous en avons
les plus grandes craintes concernant son
application concrète très clairement ce
texte prévoit de donner une autorité
exorbitante aux représentants de
l'État peut-être peut-on parler de tous
les pouvoirs et non à un médecin ou à un
juge sous le couvert de la nécessité de
protéger la société la loi tente à créer
un régime d'exception une situation où
nos concitoyens atteint de troubles
psychiatriques pourrai être internés
sans avoir véritablement leur mots à
dire dans la même optique l'intervention
du juge des libertés et de la détention
semblait positive cet élan de respect
des droits fondamentaux n'est évidemment
pas sans rapport avec la décision du
Conseil
constitutionnel bien sûr on peut que se
satisfaire que l'hospitalisation sans
consentement puisse faire l'objet d'une
décision Jud ire même si nous estimons
qu'elle devrait se faire dans un délai
plus court mais quand nous lisons le
texte du projet de loi nous avons une
curieuse impression une impression que
votre cabinet madame la ministre pour ne
pas déroger au caractère globalement
liberticide de ce texte à encadrer cette
disposition de manière à ce que son
impact positif soit très limité par
exemple le délai annoncé et bien trop
large 2 semaines c'est inadmissible dans
le cadre d'une mesure privative de
liberté si l'on prend un exemple
comparable en matière de droits des
étrangers maintenu en rétention
l'intervention du juge des libertés est
obligatoire après 4 jours l'intervention
du juge des liber puis le président du
TGI peut intervenir après 12 jours
autrement dit la mesure de rétention est
examiné deux fois comment dans ces
conditions imaginez qu'en matière de
psychiatrie sur ces 12 premiers jours
d'hospitalisation le juge des libertés
puisse être totalement absent deuxème
interrogation sur l'intervention du juge
des libertés à notre avis votre texte ne
fait que donner l'illusion que le juge
décide comp tenu du manque de moyens
criant dans le système judiciaire ne
permettant pas d'examen approfondi des
cas il y a fort à parier que cette
décision du juge reposera sur un
consentement pré présumé en en faveur de
l'hospitalisation cela d'autant plus que
rien ne vient renforcer concrètement les
droits des personnes hospitalisées de
fait alors que nous aurions pu imaginer
que ces personnes pourraient bénéficier
des avancées récentes sur la procédure
de garde à vue il n'y a rien ici qui
laisse à penser que les prisonniers
psychiatriques en bénéficieraient nous
craignons ainsi que l'objectif de
défense des libertés individuelles soit
irréaliste cont tenu des dispositions
qui sont censées et garantir dans ce
projet de loi une autre de ces mesures
que nous ne pouvons que combattre
concerne la création d'un véritable
casier
psychiatrique comment imaginer qu'une
mesure d'hospitalisation puisse être
prise sur la base d'antécédents
psychiatriques datant de plus de 20 ans
n'y a-t-il pas là un non respect
flagrant du droit à l'oubli oui mes
chers collègues là encore le droit des
malades est oublié sacrifie F à
l'objectif sécuritaire il faut les
repérer les ficher il faut les suivre
les pister ces personnes atteintes de
troublees psychiatrique parce que l'on
sait elles sont inguérissables
inguérissables comme l'est certainement
la jeunesse un peu agité de nos
quartiers la jeunesse dont l'on se
propose de repérer les comportements
déviants dès le berceau ce que vous
certains voudrai faire oui ce traitement
sécuritaire de la maladie psychiatrique
le prouve vous avez un imaginez un texte
qui enferme non un texte qui guérit
comment enfin ne pas évoquer votre
nouvelle définition des soins sans
consentement qui englobe les anciennes
hospitalisations de fice et
hospitalisation sur demande d'un tiers
en terme de nouveauté le texte prévoit
que ces soins pourront être délivré à
l'hôpital et en ambulatoire c'est là le
cœur de votre réforme selon nous il
convient d'être très prudent sur la
fausse bonne idée qui peut-être la
décision de délivrer les soins à
domicile certes le patient quit un
environnement hospitalier les familles
peuvent se croire et se sentir rassuré
mais cela pose plusieurs questions qui
porte la responsabilité du malade la
famille qu'en est-il du secret médical
comment interviennent les soignants dans
ce contexte aucune réponse véritable à
ces questions dans le projet de loi la
question qui soutend cette proposition
est simple et renvoie au principal
problèmes que nous avons déjà évoqué
notre médecine psychiatrique après 40
années d'une remarquable évolution se
meurt se délite nos hôpitaux voient
leurs moyen se réduire drastiquement de
PLFSS en PLFSS avec des personnels moins
nombreux plus sollicités en souffrance
eux aussi la VAP la valorisation de de
l'activité en psychiatrie pendant en
psychiatrie de la tarification à
l'activité veut contraindre à
sélectionner les patients demain
l'hôpital public choisira les moins
malades les moins vieux les moins fous
encore une réflexion qui m'a été faite à
Lyon par un psychiatre pour être clair
cette mesure nous donne l'impression que
l'on cherche à se débarrasser à moindre
frais d'une population et en transférer
la charge à des familles complètement
démunies parce que ce texte ne pose
aucunement la question du traitement
cette disposition est très cohérente
avec sa logique d'ensemble celle de la
prise en charge du trouble psychiatrique
dans la seule dimension sécuritaire et
non dans sa dimension thérapeutique
enfin c'est l'esprit général de stex qui
nous interpelle que men témoigne le rôle
prépondérant du préfet dans le choix de
l'encadrement voir son pouvoir
véritablement discrétionnaire puisqu'il
peut imposer une réadmission du patient
hôpital psychiatrique en cas de problème
lors du parcours de soins oui même si
vous vous en défendez vous ne considérez
la psychiatrie que sous le seul angle de
l'ordre public vos textes condamne
stigmati les personnes atteintes de
troubles mentaux sous couvert dans
protéger la société il banalise un
régime d'exception c'est très grave nous
ne pourrons que citer ce qu'en pensent
les soignants par exemple docteur Hervé
bobza porte-parole du collectif des 39
qui ne peut que constater avec nous le
recul fondamental que constitue ce texte
il nous dit la psychiatrie a besoin de
soins de se montrer hospitalière et non
pas d'endosser les habits du carcéral et
du tout médicament comme le soutend ce
texte de loi ce n'est pas de répression
d'enfermement de contrainte qu' d'abord
besoin ces personnes mais
d'accompagnement basé sur la confiance
de soin de de moyens donnés à leur
soignants quant à la psychiatrie elle
mérite une véritable loi cadre
définissant missions et moyens moyens
pérenes en conséquence nous ne pourrons
que voter contre ce texte je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à anne-emarie
paayet pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 16
minutes
monsieur
président monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues le
présent projet de loi relatif aux soins
psychiatriques sans consentement est un
texte intermédiaire intermédiaire entre
d'une part une simple mise en conformité
constitutionnelle du droit en vigueur et
d'autre part une réforme cadre du droit
de la santé mentale et c'est bien ce
caractère intermédiaire qui le rend
problématique en effet cela a déjà été
rappelé une intervention législative
était imposée par la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel du 26 novembre
2010 prise sur le fondement d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité cette décision donne
au gouvernement jusqu'au 1er août 2011
pour organiser un recours systématique
du juge judiciaire en cas de maintien
d'une hospitalisation sans
consentement ce qui se comprend bien
l'autorité judiciaire étant
constitutionnellement gardienne de la
liberté individuel ce qui est étonnant
c'est que ce contrôle systématique n'ait
pas été prévu
plutôt dans sa décision le Conseil
établit une distinction entre conditions
d'admission en hospitalisation sans
consentement et maintien de
l'hospitalisation il estime les
premières conformes à la Constitution
mais pas les secondes ainsi le texte qui
nous est soumis prévoit d'une part un
contrôle de plein droit par le juge des
libertés et de la détention des
hospitalisation sans consentement avant
le 15e jour lorsque leur durée doit se
prolonger au-delà de cette échéance et
d'autre part son intervention tous les 6
mois en cas de
prolongation le texte aurait pu se
borner à organiser ce contrôle mais il
n'en est rien puisque son objet dépasse
largement ce seul volet judiciaire il
comprend également un volet médical qui
réforme en profondeur le système
jusqu'ici établi par la loi du 27 juin
1990 en effet ce texte remplace la
notion d'hospitalisation sans
consentement par celle de soins sans
consentement donc en développant des
alternatif à l'hospitalisation complète
créer une nouvelle procédure
d'hospitalisation sans consentement en
cas de péril imminent pour la santé du
malade et une période d'observation de
soins de 72 he renforce le suivi des
patients réputés les plus difficiles
élargit et renforce le droit des
personnes en soin sans consentement la
simple énumération de ces mesure tant
médicale que judiciaire permet de se
rendre compte qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
texte à vocation exclusivement
sécuritaire contrairement à ce qui a pu
lui être reproché loin sans faux tout en
allant bien au-delà de ce qu'imposéit la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le présent texte
n'est pas non plus pour autant la grande
loi sur sur la santé mentale préconisé
par la commission couti en 2008 et par
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
politiques de santé en avril 2009 une
telle loi aborderait ce dossier sous
toutes ses facettes à savoir la
prévention des troubles psychiatriques
l'accès à des soins rapides et adaptés
donc l'offre de soins tant du point de
vue de sa quantité que de sa répartition
le suivi de la personnalité la
rénovation de l'hospitalisation sans
consentement elle-même et l'organisation
des soins au dé tenu cette loi cadre
nous l'appelions de nos vœux parce que
seule une approche globale nous paraît
garante d'une réforme cohérente en la
matière nous regrettons que ce ne soit
pas le choix fait aujourd'hui le choix
est celui d'un entre deux et les
difficultés auxquelles nous sommes
maintenant confrontés sont inhérentes à
ce type de choix ce n'est pas un hasard
si elle concerne tant le volet médical
du projet que son volet
judiciaire qu'est-ce qui est reproché à
ce texte de ne pas aller assez loin pas
assez loin dans l'explicitation de ce
que seraient ces fameux soins
ambulatoires sans consentement et c'est
tout l'enjeu de l'énorme travail réalisé
par mugadini avec la commission des
affaires sociales ces amendements n'ont
pas été intégrés au texte mais ils ont
l'immense mérite d'avoir mis en lumière
l'importante lacune du projet de loi sur
ce point c'est déjà un énorme acquis de
notre haute assemblée pour résumer voici
un texte audacieux sur le plan de la
rénovation du système un texte qui va
donc dans le bon sens la réforme
médicale qu'il porte n'a rien
d'anecdotique elle présente l'immense
mérite de responsabiliser les médecins
c'est aussi un texte fondamental sur le
plan des droits et des libertés son
volet judiciaire ne saurait être différé
bref un texte qui parvient à un
équilibre entre les gro les trois grands
enjeux du dossier que sont la santé les
droits individuels et la sûreté mais ce
texte ne saurait être adopté en l'état
parce qu'il est incomplet alors mes
chers collègues c'est la logique même
nous ne sortirons de cette situation
qu'en comblant les lacunes de ce texte
c'est-à-dire en le poussant un peu plus
loin c'est vrai la nion nouvelle de
soins ambulatoires et sans consentement
demeure problématique c'est pourquoi
nous soutiendrons l'amendement de
clarification et de compromis présenté
par notre collègue Alain Milon et
sous-amendé par le rapporteur de notre
commission des affaires sociales
Jean-Louis Laurin cet amendement précise
que les soins psychiatriques sans
consentement sont administrés au moyen
de tous les outils thérapeutiques
adaptés à l'état du patient et établit
une typologie non plus des formes de
soins mais des lieux de soins ainsi
distingue-il clairement les unités
d'hospitalisation de temps plein des
autres lieux de soins que sont les
unités alternativ à l'hospitalisation
temps plein les lieux de consultation
les lieux d'activité thérapeutiques et
les lieux de vie habituel du patient le
sous-amendement du rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales sera
sans doute quant à lui de a rassuré le
corps médical quant à sa liberté
entièrement conservée de prescription
sous réserve de ces modifications
d'importance le groupe de l'Union
centriste soutiendra cette réforme en
attendant qu'elle soit complétée dans
les meilleurs délis pour une rénovation
globale du cadre des soins
psychiatriques il ne me reste plus qu'à
féliciter nos commissions et nos
rapporteurs pour l'excellence de leur
travail mugat dinier et Jean-Louis
laourin pour la commission des affaires
sociales Jean-René le SER pour la
commission des lois avec tout de même si
vous me permz é une mention spéciale
pour mugadini qui avec le courage et la
détermination que nous lui connaissons
est allé jusqu'au bout de ses
convictions merci de votre
attention merci mes chers
collègues la parole est à Laurent
betteille pour le groupe
UMP pardon excusez-moi la parole est à
Jackie Len que je voulais indument privé
de parole ou sans doute un acte manqué
commence
mal la parole est à Monsieur
lomen Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues en l'enfermant dans une
approche résolument sécuritaire ce
projet de loi caricature la réponse que
le gouvernement entend apporté à une
grave question dont l'étude d'impact
nous révèle toute l'ampleur celle-ci
nous rappelle en effet qu'en 2005 plus
du tiers des Français ont souffert d'au
moins un trouble mental dans leur vie
nous mesurons donc l'ampleur de cette
question de santé publique qui appelait
une réponse ambitieuse tel n'est pas le
cas avec ce texte partisan et confus
même après les modifications votées par
la majorité parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale modification elle-même en
retrait par rapport au proposition de sa
commission des affaires sociales voire
de son rapporteur pour notre part nous
souhaitons une nous souhaitions une
grande loi globale de santé mentale loi
dont notre pays a besoin qui aurait
amélioré après 20 ans d'application la
loi du 27 juin 1990 dont je rappelle un
point fort a été de consacré
l'hospitalisation libre comme régime
habituel d'hospitalisation alors
qu'auparavant depuis la loi de 1838 on
ne connaissait que les modes de
placement sous contrainte or aujourd'hui
on nous propose un projet de loi qui est
perçu par les milieux professionnels
concernés comme desessensces
sécuritaires doit-on s'en étonner bien
sûr que non la naissance de ce projet de
loi à la suite d'un fait divers
dramatique rappelé d'ailleurs par mon
collègue ficher c'était en novembre 2008
dans une rue de grenobble un étudiant
est tué par un malade mar en FuG dans
l'établissement de soins quelques jours
plus tard le président de la République
annonce un plan de sécurisation des
hôpitaux psychiatriques avec une
multiplication des champ d'isolement
l'instauration de bracelet électronique
et cetera le président exige également
une nouvelle loi sur les
hospitalisations sans consentement avec
en ligne de mire la dangerosité non pas
d'une infime minorité des malades durit
souvent sans soin au moment des faits
dramatique dans lequel ils sont
impliqués mais la dangerosité supposée
de tous nos concitoyens un recours à des
soins psychiatriques dans le champ large
divers et complexe de la maladie mentale
d'une manière générale ce qui ressort ce
projet de loi dans sa version initiale
c'est l'idée de garantir la sûreté non
des malades qui pourtant ont
légitimement le plus besoin mais des non
malades en insistant par exemple sur les
prérogatives du préfet en 2006 déjà le
gouvernement dans lequel l'actuel
président de la République était
ministre de l'Intérieur avait dû
renoncer face à la mobilisation de nos
concitoyens à associer maladie mental et
dangerosité dans la loi sur la
prévention de la dé en quelque sorte les
malades mentaux étaient assimilés à des
délinquants aujourd'hui avec ce projet
de loi le gouvernement revient à la
charge la question du trouble à l'ordre
public prédomine sur la préoccupation
sanitaire et sur celle de la qualité des
soins à donner aux malades l'ossature de
ce projet demeure donc sécuritaire
observons par ailleurs que le point
central du projet de loi qui nous est
soumis est celui des soins sans
consentement avec notamment la création
de la notion de soins sans consentement
en ambulatoire cette approche est
difficile à admettre de manière générale
dans le champ médical tant il est
délicat de vouloir et de pouvoir soigner
les personnes sans leur consentement
mais c'est encore plus délicat en
psychiatrie en effet la psychiatrie
outre le recours au médicens même très
performant la relation l'alliance
thérapeutique entre le malade et sa et
son tirapotte est essentiel elle repose
sur la confiance il s'agit d'un contrat
implicite et souvent explicite qui
appelle le consentement du patient si on
recherche effectivement des résultats
thérapeutiques en la matière
l'imposition de soins sans consentement
en ambulatoire prévu par ce projet de
loi pose problème notons également que
ce texte était sur le point d'être
soumis au Parlement lorsqu intervenu la
décision du Conseil constitutionnelle du
26 novembre 2010 saisie par le Conseil
d'État dans le cadre d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité visant
à qualifier la nature juridique
l'hospitalisation d'un malade sans fond
consentement la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel stipule que ce type
d'hospitalisation est une mesure de
détention par privation pour la personne
concernée de sa liberté d'aller et de
venir au sens de la Constitution et non
une CIN mesure de protection cette
décision a donc conduit le le Conseil
constitutionnel à rappeler au
gouvernement que s'agissant d'une
privation de liberté les mesures
d'hospitalisation sans consentement
doivent être soumises au contrôle
effectif du juge judiciaire et qu'en
conséquence était inconstitutionnel les
dispositions de la loi de 1990 ne
prévoyant l'intervention de l'autorité
judiciaire qu'en cas de demande de sorti
du patient rejeté par l'autorité
compétente cette décision impose que le
juge statut d l'UR que la mesure est
prolongée au-delà de 15 jours puis à
intervalle régulier demande est donc
faite au gouvernement et au législateurs
de mettre en conformité notre
législation en la matière avant le 1er
août 2011 remarquons que la brièvité de
ce délai n'est n'est pas sans poser des
problèmes de faisabilité matérielle très
pratique manque de magistrat manque de
personnel manque de lieux d'audience
adapté et cetera sur laquelle le
gouvernement se monte peu Locass cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel est
donc venue contrarier le projet de loi
tout sécuritaire que le gouvernement et
le président de la République
envisageait de faire voter au Parlement
la réécriture du projet initial de
rechef entreprise dans sa h dans la h et
la confusion avec un AAT de consultation
des acteurs concernés associatifs
professionnels institutionnel nous donne
une une production incrémentale d'un
projet de loi où peu d'acteurs s'y
retrouvent et ce n'est là qu'un ehémisme
les auditions conduites nous ont
confirmer l'insatisfaction généralisée
et parfois une opposition frontale aux
10 projets pour des motifs multiples
pertinent et solide une bonne synthèse
de cette insatisfaction se retrouve dans
l'avis de la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme avis
adopté en assemblée plinièire le 31 mars
2011 ainsi je retiendrai premièrement
concernant les interrogations sur le
régime avenir celui-ci est loin de faire
l'unanimité chez les professionnels les
malades et leurs proches leur inquiétude
de tout ordre s'agissant des procédures
complexe se focalise sur la crainte que
la réforme renforce au-delà de
l'indispensable la contrainte an sur les
malades à la différence de nombreux pays
la France a progressivement renoncé à
une politique de secteur qui avait
suscité de grands espoirs au profit d'un
renforcement du recours à
l'hospitalisation ce qui est d'autant
plus paradoxal que nous savons
l'importance des restructuration
budgétaire et des milliers de
suppressions d'emplois et de lits dans
les hôpitaux dans un contexte marqué par
une insuffisance de moyens et des
difficultés de recrutement des
spécialistes médicaux et infirmiers une
concurrence non résolue entre les
dépenses exigées pour les établissements
et la médecine des secteurs ce séjour
obligatoire en établissement prévu par
le projet de loi favorise la formule de
l'internement en outre le système
d'expertise sur lequel repose tout le
jeu des certificats et d'examen par un
collège des différentes étapes du
nouveau dispositif est jugé par beaucoup
très complexe voire pratiquement
inapplicable compte tenu de
l'insuffisance des effectifs et surtout
inégalment réparti sur le territoire
d'où laattrainte que ce système
d'expertise ne puisse dégager le sort
des malades mentaux de l'amalgame qui
conduit à privilégier un point de vue
sécuritaire et pour éviter tout risque
enfermé plutôt que d'organiser les
moyens d'un accompagnement c'est un des
grands dangers de cette loi c'estàd
faire passer le sécuritaire avant le
thérapeutique ce qui est une ineptiie
que tous les rapports mettent en avant
en affirmant chiffre à l'appui que ce
sont avant tout les personnes ayant des
troubles mentaux qui sont les victimes
de violence de plus maintenant pour
beaucoup de professionnels l'impression
s'est faite jour que nous nous dirigeons
vers une judiciarisation renforcer la
psychiatrie qu'il réfute non sans
fondement les malades mentaux ne sont
pas de dangereux délinquants à cela
j'ajoute le fait que la loi reste flou
bien flou sur la portée réelle en terme
de liberté publique de cette innovation
que constituent les soins sans
consentement en ambulatoire
qu'implique-t-il en pratique pour le
droit d'aller et de venir de protection
du domicile de rapport avec les proches
et dans d'autres lieux de vie qu'en
est-il du libre choix de son médecin par
le malade des actes de la vie courante
les conséquences d'un refus de se prêter
au traitement sont-elles le retour ou
l'envoi en établissement il est
difficile à la seule lecture du projet
de mesurer les véritable suggestion
autre que médicales qui doivent être
précisé et assorti de garantie d'où le
sentiment que la concertation permettant
un véritable consensus dans ce domaine
très sensible n'est pas allé assez loin
et que la concomitance des réformes et
des moyens n'est pas réalisée le patient
sera plus isolé que jamais dans une
société hostile et face à une réforme
dont il considera le cobail plus
particulièrement il ne paraît pas
acceptable de retenir des critères comme
le passage devant la justice ou dans des
unités pour malade difficile pour
imposer à un malade parce qu'il a eu un
épisode critique un régime juridique
plus sévère il a droit à ce que
l'appréciation de son cas se fasse sur
la seule base des nécessités de son
traitement et sous la responsabilité de
son médecin qui soit évidemment
appréhender qui doivent évidemment
appréhender tous les problèmes liés à la
vie en société de son malade deè
concernant le contrôle du juge sur les
décisions prises dans sans le
consentement du malade on se demande si
la réforme n'est pas restée au milieu du
gay et s'il n'aurait pas été plus
opportun de faire intervenir le contrôle
du juge dès la décision initiale
d'hospitalisation et non pas simplement
à postériori même si le Conseil
constitutionnel n'est pas allé aussi
loin la question peut légitimement être
posée c'est en effet une solution qui
fonctionne apparemment bien dans
certains pays qui ont mis en pratique ce
recours aux juges dans la réponse au
problème il est d'autre part clair que
le sort des inéressés n'est pas facilité
par la succession de mesures impliquant
des responsabilités successives on
ajoutera que toutes les appréciations
reposent évidemment sur des avis
médicaux dont la contestation est
malaisée et ce d' plus que le juge
interviendra alors que le diagnostic et
même le traitement seront déjà décidés
pour écarter cette option pourtant
souhaité par les associations de malades
et une partie des magistrats l'étude
d'impact avance l'argument assez
théorique qui ne serait pas bon que le
juge de libertés de détention appelé à
exercer une fonction de contrôle et pris
une position dès l'origine mais le
Conseil constitutionnel a lui surtout
avancé l'argument de la surcharge de
travail des juges ce qui est prévisible
et doit être anticipé sérieusement nous
pensons que le gouvernement pour des
raison d'économie budgétaire a plutôt
été sensible à ce dernier argument pour
notre part nous estimons que ce dernier
ne doit pas déterminer la réponse à
partir du moment où l'on s'engage dans
une réforme d'importance il faut se
donner les moyens matériels et humains
suffisant pour la mettre en œuvre dans
le même ordre d'ilé il étonnant que le
contrôle du juge ne porte pas sur les
soins sans consentement lorsqu'ils sont
prescrits en ambulatoire le placement
des soins ambulatoires hors du contrôle
du juge paraît dénué de fondement il y
aurait au contraire grand intérêt à
ouvrir aux juges ce contentieux
particulièrement sensible au regard du
respect de la vie privée s'agissant d'un
autre point de ce projet de loi on
pourrait aussi imaginer que soit créé un
bloc de compét au préfit du juge
judiciaire c'est du reste ce qui est
proposé par le rapporteur de notre
commission des loi afin que celui-ci
connaisse de l'intégralité du
contentieux du soin psychiatrique
contraint la concurrence entre la
compétence du juge administratif pour
connaître des décisions du directeur de
l'établissement et celle du juge
judiciaire pour décider du maintien de
l'hospitalisation sans contrainte ou de
la main levée de celle-ci n'est guerre
satisfaisante concernant la mise en
œuvre du contrôle jurddictionnel des
difficultés pratiques apparaissent
évidente la possibilité d'un recours à
la visioconférence pour organiser ces
audiences prévues par le projet et par
exemple un point de vive contestation
des raisons budgétaires ne sauraient
justifier cette pratique hautement
critiable dans un contentieux qui
s'adresse à des personnes en situation
souvent d'extrême fragilité le dialogue
entre le juge et le patient est rendu
difficile sinon impossible la place de
l'avocat qui ne pourra se trouver à la
fois au tribunal et auprès de son client
lui interdit en toute hypothèse
d'exercer sa fonction dans des
conditions satisfaisantes c'est donc
l'effectivité même du recours organisé
sous forme d'audition à distance qui est
compromise enfin beaucoup de
professionnels du champ psychiatrique et
de nombreux magistrats ainsi que leurs
représentants se déclarent des plus
préoccupés par la procédure de recours
suspensif à l'initiative du préfet du
directeur de l'établissement d'accueil
qu'instore le projet de loi en cas de
désaccord avec la décision de mainlev du
juge la crainte est que le principe de
précaution n'affecte une fois encore les
droits des patients tout en discréditant
les pouvoirs et l'autorité du juge à la
lumière à la lumière de ces
questionnements quand ce n'est de cesqu
inquétude on en vient à la conclusion ce
projet de loi manque de la maturité
nécessaire à une réforme convaincante du
régime actuel de la prise en charge de
la maladie mentale il semble que la
réflexion ne soit pas aboutie tant sur
la question du contrôle par l'autorité
judiciaire de la mesure de contrainte
que sur celle de la gestion de la
contrainte à l'extérieur de l'hôpital
psychiatrique dans cet exercice ultra
sensible qui demande une approche
requérant le tribuchet du pharmacien un
esprit de mesure s'impose pour trouver
un juste équilibre entre trois
dispositifs également prioritaires à
savoir un dispositif sanitaire au
service des malades le patient ne doit
pas disparaître derrière sa pathologie
son parcours ne peut se résumer à un
condensé d'existence bordé par la
médicalisation nonobstant les avancées
dans le domaine des médicaments et ou
l'infernement un dispositif judiciaire
qui garantit des libertés fondamentales
de tous les citoyens à forcerie
lorsqu'ils sont en état de faiblesse ou
malad un dispositif de sécurité du des
personnes garantissant l'ordre public
visant la protection de la société dont
doit également bénéficier le malade
dispositif qui ne soit pas un tout
sécuritaire rejetant la présence des
malades mentaux hors de la cité car
abusivement déclaré dangereux par
hypothèse ce qui vous en conviendrez mes
chers collègues est scandaleux le projet
de loi qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
ne répond pas à ce juste équilibre à
défaut de pouvoir réinclure ce texte
dans une authentique écran de loi de
santé publique toujours en attente et
faute de pouvoir bénéficier des quelques
réelles avancées proposé et je la
remercie par madame le rapporteur
initial de ce projet devant notre
commission des Affaires social
proposition qui gommet plusieurs
dispositions particulièrement
criticables et critiqué par l'ensemble
des professionnels et associations
concerné puisque son rapport a été
rejeté la semaine dernière notre groupe
a déposé de nombreux amendements
certains de ceuxci d'ailleurs reprennent
quelques amendements pertinents du
rapporteur initial que nous avions
approuvé lors de l'examen en commission
d'autres amendements s'inscrient dans la
même veine que ceux souvent très
justifiés défendus par le rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des lois
notre objectif est d'améliorer un texte
initial à l'ambiqué assemblage de
procédures complexes au point d'être
souvent contradictoire et qui en faisant
mine d'afficher le renforcement des
garanties des droits des personnes
rendent prépondérantes des décisions
administratives dictées par la
présomption de dangerosité des malades
psychiatriques et non basé sur
l'évaluation médicale des nécess so ce
qui est pour le moins déplorable voire
scandaleux pour nous pour nombre de nos
concitoyens et pour la grande majorité
des professionnel concernés pour
l'ensemble des raisons que je viens
rapidement d'évoquer sur ce projet de
loi notre groupe votreaconte je vous
remercie de votre attention merci ch
collèg pour group la parole est à
Laurent pour 8 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues j'ai beaucoup hésité
avant d'intervenir dans ce
débat j'étais prêt ce matin à demander à
être retiré la liste des orateurs parce
que lorsqu'on est directement concerné
par un sujet comme celui-là c'est
toujours difficile de d'en parler avec
une quelconque sérénité puis l'exercice
auquel je vais me livrer devant vous est
particulièrement impudique et douloureux
pour moi néanmoins j'ai persisté dans
mon idée d'intervenir parce que il y a
eu
ces projets de manifestation et cette
agitation autour de ce texte qui pour
moi relève plutôt de la caricature ou
des préjugés idéologiques et je pense
que pour les familles c'est
particulièrement insupportable d'aborder
le problème de cette
façon-là et donc je vous dirai quelques
mots sur la vie de mon fils qui que rien
apparemment ne prédestiné à être
concerné par des maladies psychiatriques
qui a eu son bac qui a commencé des
études supérieures et puis qui un beau
jour a sombré dans la schizophrénie et
quand je dis sombré c'est effectivement
un naufrage aujourd'hui il est clochard
il joue de la musique dans les rues de
l'athène et le reste de son temps il le
passe à ramasser des mégots qu'il
conserve
précieusement alors effectivement il y a
eu une dérive qui est arrivée assez
brutalement qui s'est traduit par des
hurlements qu'il pousser dans les rues
pour chasser les démons des menaces et
des brutalités envers ma femme nous
avons effectivement essayer de trouver
un moyen de le soigner mais c'est pas
facile de soigner quelqu'un qui ne se
reconnaît pas malade et qui de sur croi
considère que tous les médecins sont des
êtres systématiquement
malfaisants j'ai pu après quelques mois
et grâce à l'aide d'un psychiatre qui
est qui a accepté de venir chez moi et
de de rencontrer mon fils un peu par
surprise j'ai réussi finalement à
obtenir une hpéalisation qui a été un
peu limite par rapport à la loi de 90
mais qu'importe il a pu être soigné à ce
moment-là il a bénéficié au bout d'un
certain temps d'une permission de sortie
qui s'est traduit comme c'est
généralement le cas par un arrêt
progressif mais prématuré du traitement
et non donc pas
abouti à ce que nous espérions le
problème a perduré il a a amené toute
une série de péripéties qu'il n'est pas
ici opportun de
rappeler mais je peux vous dire que pour
la famille pour les proches pour les
amis ça a été particulièrement pénible
et surtout
aujourd'hui je considère que ce garçon
est dans
une il a sa vie qui est
gâchée il a il est dans une situation de
souffrance particulière par parce que
tout ce queil imagine ce sont des
déceptions qu'il ne comprend pas et je
crois qu'effectivement il est beaucoup
plus victime de violence que auteur de
violence parce que effectivement tout le
monde peut abuser de lui sans aucune
difficulté il est d'une grande naïveté
et par conséquent c'est une victime
potentielle évidente alors si je vous ai
raconté ça c'est
pas c'est surtout pour vous demander
d'aborder ce débat avec un état d'esprit
positif et parce que il me semble
vraiment nécessaire
aujourd'hui qu'on prenne les
dispositions qui sont dans ce projet de
loi une par une pour voir celles qui
sont utiles aux malades je souhaiterais
vraiment qu'on aborde les questions qui
sont dans ce texte avec ce souci de
penser d'abord au malade et pas à
d'autres considérations dont
malheureusement on a trop entendu
et
puis je voudrais dire aussi que je suis
membre de la commission des lois j'ai
entendu les propositions qui ont été
faites par Jean-René lcer j'ai pris
connaissance d'un certain nombre
de de proposition également de la
commission des affaires sociales je
pense qu'effectivement ce texte
peut-être amélioré dans le sens d'un
meilleur contrôle notamment
juridictionnel mais je souhaite vraiment
que tout ce qui peut améliorer le
fonctionnement de la loi 4 90 soit
adopté dans ce débat
merci la parole est à anne-emarie
Escoffier pour le groupe
RDSE monsieur le président madame la
ministre je voudrais dire à à mon
collègue que je m'inscris exactement
comme beaucoup de mes collègues du
groupe dans la même démarche qui veut
être généreuse et prendre en compte les
vrais besoins de soin de nos malades
fragilisés madame la ministre d'autres
l'ont dit avant moi et le diront après
moi notre Haute Assemblée est confrontée
à une situation inédite après le travail
en commission commission des affaires
sociales et commission des lois le texte
reproposé nous revient celui de
l'Assemblée nationale non amendé comment
ne pas regretter ce retour
exanté qui ignore les longs et fructueux
débats conduit par le rapporteur de la
commission des lois avec la rigueur et
le talent qu'on lui connaît je voudrais
ici saluer la qualité extrême de son
travail et regretter bien sûr le sort
fait aux amendements que nous aurions dû
voir intégré aujourd'hui au texte je
dirais de la même façon pour la
commission des lois les regrets qui sont
les miens de ne pas pouvoir entendre et
voir un texte que vous auriez enrichi je
n'interviendrai ici madame la ministre
sur ce projet de loi que sur le volet
judiciaire relevant de la commission à
laquelle j'ai l'honneur d'appartenir un
projet de loi qui entend définir un
nouvel équilibre entre trois principes à
valeur constitutionnell le droit à la
ection de la santé la protection de
l'ordre public et la protection de la
liberté individuelle il semble bien
qu'il soit la conséquence directe de
laavue rendue par le Conseil
constitutionnel le 26 novembre 2010 qui
avait déclaré contraire à la
Constitution l'article l337 devenu
l32127 du code de la santé publique qui
ne soumettit pas le maintien de
l'hospitalisation d'une personne sans
son consentement à une juridiction
judiciire
gardienne des libertés
individuelles s'il était donc bien
légitime que soit corrigé C disposition
on peut néanmoins s'interroger sur
l'ampleur du nouveau dispositif qui
répond une nouvelle fois et je le
regrette à l'événem cel et n'a pas pris
suffisamment le temps d'examiner toutes
les conséquences de ses choix en
particulier le yatus semble grande entre
les options posées au plan de la santé
et leurs conséquences en matière
judiciaire je n'en veut pour preuve que
les termes mêmes de l'avis du Conseil
constitutionnel qui statuant sur les
droits des personnes hospitalisées sans
leur consentement indique au point 38
considérant que l'article l351 du code
de la santé publique reconnaît à toute
personne hospitalisé sans son
consentement ou retenu dans quelque
établissement que ce soit le droit de se
pourvoir par simple requête à tout
moment devant le président du tribunal
de grande instance pour qu'il soit mis
fin à l' hitalisation sans consentement
que le droit de saisir le juge est
également reconnu à toute personne
susceptible d'intervenir dans l'intérêt
de la personne
hospitalisée pourquoi madame la ministre
mais la question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre garde desess saau avoir
généralisé cette mesure et systématiser
le recours aux juges judiciaires à
toutes les hospitalisations sous
contrainte le système proposé met
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté autant
le milieu judiciaire que le monde des h
phopsychiatrique et des psychiatres
mêmees il suffit de voir et d'entendre
les réactions nombreuses des
professionnels pour mesurer le désarrois
des uns et des autres un texte trop
complexe qui aurait dû en réalité faire
l'objet de deux textes distinct parce
que relatif à des sujets spécifiques je
voudrais dire en particulier
l'inquiétude des magistrats qui voi
augmenter leur charg à un niveau
insupportable l'étude d'impact elle-même
soune l'absolue nécessité de créer des
emplois dont on est en droit de savoir
comment ils seront financés
multiplication du nombre des cas soumis
au contrôle judiciaire dans les 15 jours
de l'admission ou de la décision
multiplication du nombre des contrôles
eux-mêmes répétés tous les 6 mois
multiplication des expertises
psychiatriques concours nombreux
demander à des collèges de soignants
dans un contexte médical dont on connaît
la fragilité délaiis brefs imposés aux
juges conformément à la jurisprudence de
la Cour européenne qui seront très vite
inaccepable organisation d'un débat
contradictoire entre le juge et les
médecins sans qu'il soit préciser de
quel médecin il s'agit mesure aussi
difficile sinon impossible à mettre en
œuvre la
visionférence cette mesure ignore
manifestement l'organisation des
hôpitaux psychiatriques
et le manque de leurs moyens budgétaires
pour mettre en place ses équipements au
total mais nous y reviendrons au cours
des débats face à une intention louable
celle de protéger des personnes
fragilisées le gouvernement propose un
dispositif dont la complexité ne pourra
en aucun cas garantir parfaitement aucun
des trois principes essentiels
républicain que nous avons rappelés je
veux dans ces conditions
être confiante dans le bon sens la
sagesse le réalisme des ministres sur
ces bancs qui écouteront j'en suis sû
nos interrogations et nos inquiétudes
celles des personnes fragilisées et de
leur famille pour donner toute priorité
aux
soins merci ma cher collègue la parole
est à Al Milon pour le groupe
UMP
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs dans
notre monde 400 millions de personnes
sont concernées par un trouble mental au
niveau national il est à observer que de
nos jours presque un français sur qu
souffre d'une de ces formes de trouble
et que ces types de maladie touche de
plus en plus de jeunes adultes comme on
nous l'a dit et des personnes âgées cela
doit nous faire prendre conscience que
ces maladies affectent la vie de bon
nombre de nos concitoyens de tous âges
et de toutes conditions qu'elle
détériore parfois la qualité de vie et M
aussi souvent en danger leur insertion
dans la société peu de personnes
souffrant de ces troubles en parle
publiquement la santé mentale c'est
intime c'est caché c'est secret c'est
tabout et les préjugés négatifs ont
malheureusement la vie dure cela devient
public lorsque l'expression du trouble
et de l'angoisse deviennent trop
intenses quand sont perturbé la vie
familiale le milieu du travail ou plus
généralement la société car l'image du
malade mental reste aux yeux du grand
public très archaïque celui ici reste
une personne imprévisible dangereuse qui
nécessite un placement en établissement
psychiatrique pour être suivi et soigné
l'objet de la psychiatrie n'est pas le
trouble mental mais l'être humain
souffrant de trouble mental la société
évolue et pourtant les malades mentaux
ont été les moins écoutés et les moins
considérés du système de soins pendant
longtemps quand il est vrai que le
trouble psychique inquiète toujours par
son étrangeté contribuant
malheureusement à renforcer l'isolement
de celui qui en souffre
Montaigne n'écrivait-elle pas en son
temps on construit des maisons de fou
pour faire croire à ceux qui n'y sont
pas enfermés qu'ils ont encore la raison
or tout changement profond en senté
mentale passe par un changement
d'attitude de la société vis-à-vis de
ses cons citoyen là selon les chiffres
de l'OMS en 20 ans nous passerons de 10
à plus de 20 % de Français touchés par
au moins une pathologie mentale en 30
ans le nombre de dépressions déclaré a
été multiplié par 6 il est donc bon de
rappeler à tout le monde qu'il peut-être
concerné de près ou de loin par un
trouble psychique d'ailleurs au cours de
ces dernières années le nombre de
personnes suivies a très consid blement
augmenté que ce soit dans le dispositif
public ou dans le dispositif privé des
réformes comme dans les autres domaines
sont donc nécessaires car le chantier
est j'en suis convaincu immense parler
de santé mentale c'est parler bien plus
que de médecine c'est aussi madame le
ministre se préoccuper d'insertion et
être attentif à l'accompagnement social
des personnes concernées mais aussi
celui de leur entourage proche c'est
aussi mettre les moyens suffisants dont
la psychiatrie a besoin en particulier
en formation et plus particulièrement
encore la formation des infirmiers
psychiatriques le champ de la santé
mentale est donc particulièrement étendu
puisque tout autre domaine de la santé
il recouvre à la fois une dimension
individuelle et une dimension
sociétale la santé mentale occupe une
place considérable au sein de notre
système de santé du fait de la fréquence
des troubles ainsi que d'une offre
importante mais insuffisante en
équipement et en
personnel l'angoisse est partout
aujourd'hui il y a une explosion de la
demande d'opsie et l' attend des
spécialistes qu'il répondre dans
l'urgence la consommation de psychotrope
est très importante puisque la sécurité
sociale paye plus de 315 millions
d'antagique et 122 millions
d'hypnotiques et de tranquillisants
encore que prescription ne veuilleent
pas dire consommation est- àdire que les
Français ont mal sont mal ou qu'ils vont
mal par ailleurs il est certain que les
changements de repères structurant tant
au niveau de l'entreprise qu'au niveau
de la société pour l'être humain se
reflète au niveau des troubles de la
personnalité avec augmentation des
troubles du type borderline diagnostic
fréquemment retenu aujourd'hui enfin il
convient de mentionner un autre
changement la place du malade par
rapport à la maladie autrefois très
passif et sommet de suivre ce qui était
imposé il est devenu un partenaire et si
possible un acteur de son traitement la
nécessité de l'information est
aujourd'hui un truisme et il faut aller
plus loin dans l'application du patient
il est vrai que le traitement est une
démarche de longue haleine pour pouvoir
traiter quelqu'un il faut établir un
lien avec lui afin de pouvoir travailler
ensemble ce qui prend du temps c'est
pourquoi l'examen de ce projet de loi
semble le signe d'une avancée la volonté
de créer un climat de confiance
d'échange et par conséquent de
protection tout en précisant que si on
peut comprendre la volonté de renforcer
la sécurité de nos concitoyens il faut
être conscient qu'elle nécessite la mise
en place de moyens considérables dont on
ne parle pas dans ce texte on aurit pu
madame la ministre espérer un texte de
santé mentale qui aurait dû être
beaucoup plus abouti que ce qui nous est
proposé aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne
les moyens il est en effet je me répète
indispensable de regarder aussi le volet
santé quels moyens seront mis en place
en terme de personnel soignant qui forme
une chaîne complète médecin psychiatre
infirmier infirmier surtout sur ce
dernier point quel effort sera fourni
pour améliorer la formation de ces
personnels notamment les infirmiers p
psiatrique dont j'ai demandé il y a 2
ans en arrière déjà leur rétablissement
dans un précédent rapport je note
toutefois que le projet de loi ajoute
des étapes intéressantes dans la
procédure de suivi des patients durant
les tous premiers jours qui n'existent
pas aujourd'hui et qui vont dans le sens
d'une meilleure prise en compte dans
compte du droit des malades sans
toutefois et je l'espère mettre le
psychiatre sous la tutelle du juge qui
est certes le protecteur des libertés
mais qui est un tiers dans la relation
médecin malade il faut savoir donner du
temps au temps il est illusoire de
penser que quelqu'un puisse sortir d'une
dépression en quelques semaines
seulement dans ce lapse de temps il est
toujours envisageable de guérir les
symptômes mais si aucun travail n'est
effectué sur le vécu du patient une
rapide rechute serait à craindre la
protection des personnes faisant l'objet
de soins psychiatriqu est peut-être
avant tout un état d'esprit où l'on
montre que la vie a en elle quelque
chose de formidable et de très
intéressant parfois il faut également
savoir se confronter à la peur et voir
que l'on dispose de toutes les
ressources nécessaires pour la dépasser
ensuite il convient de rappeler un
principe essentiel on ne laisse jamais
un individu s'enfermer dans des
comportement où il ne se nourrit
pas on ne le laisse pas si possible
se marginaliser cependant la question
d'un référent demeure non résolu les
patients sont souvent relativement
isolés même s'ils sont bien entourés et
personne ne se sent autorisé à avoir la
responsabilité de veiller à ce qu'il ne
s'enferme pas dans des conduites de
refus et on touche là l'un des problèmes
essentiels de notre société qui est
certes dotée de moyens et d'information
très riche mais qui souffrent également
d'une irresponsabilité
généralisée de plus au-delà de leur
propre maladie les patients souffrent
bien souvent de troubles qui touchent à
leur estime de soi et à leurs liens
sociaux du fait de la peur de la
récidive ou de la décompensation il
tombent parfois dans des pathologies
secondaires de la maladie qui sont les
stratégies d'adaptation les échecs
familiaux les troubles cognitifs les
conduites antisociales et les échecs
scolaires ou professionnels il faut
apprendre aux patients à vivre avec et
veiller à ne pas passer notre temps à
leur renvoyer des images non
valorisantes je suis Madame la Ministre
favorable à une déontologie de
l'Information Psychiatrique afin de
relever le double défi de faire face à
la souffrance des patients et d'apporter
des réponssees collective clinique
médicos-sociale et sociale au profit de
personnes le plus souvent vulnérables de
même comme je l'avais souligné dans le
rapport de l'Opeps dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure il est nécessaire d'adapter
l'organisation territoriale de la
psychiatrie au besoins de la population
de créer une spécialisation de niveau
Master pour les infirmiers de renforcer
les coopérations entre professionnels de
santé mentale en développant la notion
de réseau et l'un des amendements que je
présente va dans ce sens la question des
soins ambulatoires devrait également
être abordé dans le cadre plus large
d'une loi d'ensemble sur la santé
mentale car elle nécessite par exemple
de réfléchir à l'organisation de réseaux
de psychiatrie
n'ayez pas peur des fous tel est le
message que nous avons reçu chacun
d'entre nous de la part de Monier
d'établissement public de santé mentale
et méfions-nous que souscouvert de
défendre droit et protection des
personnes malades les soins sans
consentement deviennent le modèle de
soins psychique faisant de l'exception
parfois nécessaire la règle habituelle
comme le souligner également ces hommes
d'Église sans nier la complexité des
situations auxquelles nous sommes
confronté face à la Malie mentale soyons
prévoyant face au risque de disparition
d'un modèle de psychiatrie qui semble le
plus pertinent la psychiatrie
institutionnelle a transformé des
institutions aliénantes quasi carcérales
pour en faire un des outils au service
de la singularité du sujet ouvert sur la
cité en matière de santé mentale le
politique j'ai bientôt terminé le
politique est plus que jamais dans son
rôle d'arbitrage il doit répondre à la
question de savoir jusqu'où aller le
plus loin pour faire avancer une
question sensible sur un sujet aussi
douloureux tout en ne basculant pas dans
la vulgarisation excessive laquelle se
traduirait de mauvais choix politique
car il est temps de faire en sorte que
la question de la santé mentale ne soit
plus seulement l'affaire de spécialiste
mais constitue également une partie de
notre conscience collective plus éveillé
et au-delà de notre contribution il nous
faut refonder un investissement
collectif sur ces sujets c'est-à-dire
trouver les points d'entrée convaincants
et duraes je vous remercie de votre
aimable écoute merci mon cher
collègue ma parole est à Jean-Pierre
Michel pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi aborde un sujet très
délicat qui se situe à la confluence des
enjeux de liberté publique et de
sécurité publique et il faut dire très
clairement dès laabord qui ne réussit
pas à atteindre le point d'équilibre
nécessaire entre ces deux impératifs tel
que nous le connaissons d'ailleurs et
tel qu'il a été défini depuis longtemps
par une jurisprudence constante du
Conseil d'État cette loi est avant tout
une loi sécuritaire et l'aspect médical
peut-être d'ailleurs subordonné aux
interventions du préfet mais aussi du
juge et donc je vais me limiter à cet
aspect l'aspect
judiciaire l'irruption du
judiciaire dans pour la protection des
libertés publiques qui ne sera en
pratique souvent qu'une illusion très
difficile à mettre en œuvre et qui
n'apportera pas de garantie réelle du
moins c'est mon point de vue en effet de
quel information pourra disposer le juge
pour aller à l'encontre du diagnosticque
médical car l'internement sans
consentement soit à la demande d'un
tiers soit à la demande d'une autorité
préfectorale est avant tout un
traitement pour le malade psychiatrique
qui est dans un état évolutif avant
d'être une mesure de privation de
liberté et donc le juge va s'imisser
dans ce traitement pour dire non ça
suffit il faut que ce malade sorte du
traitement hospitalier c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a certainement une
très grande pratique du terrain et de
ces difficultés et de ces exigences qui
nous obligent à légiférer sous
contrainte on peut le dire depuis la
dernière réforme de la Constitution
d'ailleurs le Conseil constitutionnel
entend se comporter comme une cour
suprême encore faudrait-il que sa
constitution fournissent les garanties
d'indépendance et d'impartialité qui
caractériseent une cour suprême or ce
n'est pas le cas même si ces membres
sont honorables le nomination est une
nomination politique et pour certains
d'entre eux il faut le dire politicienne
en plus la présence des anciens
présidents de la République de fait que
renforcer à cet aspect le fait qu'il ne
siège pas ou qu'il siège importe peu il
suffit qu'il puisse siéger dans une
affaire où il pourrait emporter une
majorité souhaité par un niveau
supérieur quoi qu'il en soit la mesure
du contrôle judiciaire peut se réféer
difficilement praticable comme
d'ailleurs d'autres dispositions des
projets de loi en effet les moyens
sanitaire et judiciaire très important
qui sont requis par ce texte qui seront
requis par l'application de ce texte
contexte fortement contraste fortement
pardon avec des effectifs de la
magistrature et ceux des intervenants en
psychiatrie médecins et personnels
infirmiers et à cet égard l'étude
d'impact n'apporte pas de réponse
satisfaisante bien au contraire je
voudrais d'ailleurs rappeler que dans le
rapport que Christian demmontes Gilbert
Barbier Jean-René leerf et moi-même
avions déposé il y a 1 an sur prison et
troubles mentaux nous n'avions pas
retenu la solution imposée par le
Conseil constitutionnelle même si elle
était dans la tête de certains en
effet parce que elle nous a pas semblé
opportune d'ailleurs l'article 40 de
l'avant projet du code pénal 1978
prévoyait de permettre à l'autorité
judiciaire d'ordonner le placement puis
la sortie de la personne atteinte de
trouble mental mais cette solution a
finalement été écartée quand très
contesté comme d'autres d'ailleurs qui
avaient été prévu antérieurement car
elle tendait à confondre le rôle du juge
et celui du médecin nous quittons
l'hémicycle du Sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance nous
reviendrons bien entendu dans notre
journal de 19h sur l'examen de ce texte
consacré aux soins psychiatriques merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée à
tous